peu moi si je mène
je savais capitaine de bateau
[Musique]
et bien
quant au onze d'en-bas
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui cherchent
toutes les semaines un truc à dire à ce
moment là avec nous ce soir
chouchou quinzaine d'années
le mannequin de l'année
pascal sevran
l'inventeur du meca colin le
vice-président de france israël
les chatons atomica
le champion du monde de boxe
et notre vin blanc il est consacré ce
soir religion mais là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et maintenant ça va
ça
au salon
allez tomber à la map stade
neko bonne voie si je joue
[Applaudissements]
merci aux dallas quelle entrée je suis
chaud mais alors là si ça c'est l'entrée
compris m en sortir et ça fait plaisir
alors je joue je te regarde comme si
vous n'êtes la télé pareil bonsoir les
gens quand je parle comme juges
adressent un ça va
j'adresse avec vos et jules weppe en
ouverture totale
il connaît pas bien la télévision de sa
première télévision en tous les cas je
joue vous est l'héroïne d'un film de
merzak allouache intitulé she si un
retard elway nasa ça fait mal à la gorge
c'est un petit peu qui sort le 19 mars
comment ça va à sochaux
bon ça va bien là je dois dire sa
première fois de ma vie je mets les
pieds dans un plateau moussan vous vous
sentez bien là sur ce plateau ça va ça
va mal et je me sens bien je suis
content comme si j'étais une vedette
alors que 13 ans quand même
il comprend pas partie
g parce que je parle mais je donne le
droit c
ces lattes et c'est comme cela télévisée
la télévision d'accord ça va alors dites
moi je joue sérieusement c'est votre
vrai prénom chouchou où ça vient des
cacahuètes ou des noeuds pour les
cheveux ah non comme m non c'est un
pseudonyme
c'est à dire quand même on rigole on
rigole mais ça va il ya des moments
peut-être je vais pas rigoler je suis
gentil mais je vais pas me suis une
grande salle
[Applaudissements]
non je dois dire
je deviens bon à vous même et à toute la
france parce que la france est le regard
de ces entre la france regarde ce que ce
soit en même temps je suis juste un
pseudonyme c'est pas mon vrai nom c'est
à dire bah mon vrai nom c'est choukri et
comme j'étais je vais pas raconter toute
ma vie là mais quand même on m'appelait
cherchons pas ce qui était quelque chose
d'affectueux est facile que choukri
vous connaissez gad elmaleh les auteurs
du film
ben si je le connais suède à l'espagne
son amant à wemmel et il est plutôt
sympathique non le sympathique bon je
peux pas te raconter mais ben may mais
vous l'avez connu comme enjeu si ce
n'est pas indiscret merci ça fait
plaisir
alors là je parle on me donnait la
limonade
c'est l'un de radeaux regarde le malaise
je les connais à la place très léché ah
ouais parce que je travaille dans un
cabaret un moment donné je savais qu'il
faisait quand même la malice parce que
c'est quelqu'un tu sais tu connais
d'artistes a fourni à gauche affolé à
droite appréhension un jour tu te
retrouves de l'ulb et où il allait il
allait à l'apocalypse ghana le même où
elle allait la pokal et un bon ouais
ouais
et le plus beau mec non quand même des
west ham beau gosse est un beau gosse
mais il a des yeux et la 18 du bichon et
vise les faits sans fantasme
j-pr tc pourquoi j'ai peur l'ardhis eaux
utilisées pour sa part parce qu'ils lui
demandant l'arrêt va dire pas jeudi vers
10 ans et puis on est beaucoup regardé
au maghreb en algérie en tunisie au
maroc je sais bien d'ailleurs je salue
la maghrebi tout entière moi aussi
d'ailleurs moi aussi je joue
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous faisiez
avant de faire du cinéma avant de faire
décidément ouais je travaille et qu'on a
assistante d'une psychanalyste je
travaille aussi comme serveuse à
l'apocalypse avec un jus rencontrer des
gens je faisais du cocktail gervais les
gens je faisais l'ambiance 1 je pouvais
chanter peut-être des milliers de
chansons je pouvais être dans une
ambiance et une gaieté qui pourrait
laisser entrevoir que quand même si vous
m'arrêtez assis un moment donné c'est
trop lassés jeu pouvait entrevoir que la
vie était belle dans un élément de
risque seront bien un cabaret à savoir
l'apocalypse l'âge accueillir les gens
des fois je prend le micro avec les dix
daily deals les dj comme tu dis et wade
fois didier manie tandis air connu
alors ce midi l'ambiance j'aurais
marpiré les pieds là l'auteur gars de
lima et m'a dit tu veux faire du cinéma
jeudi mais tu te fous de ma gueule me
dit non pas du tout laisse tomber
l'apocalypse et en avant les dollars
c'est un cinéma c'est pas des birom a
séduit la france c'est pas évident que
c'est le dollar a cédé euros ouais ouais
vous allez coucher pour réussir
est-ce que j'ai coaché pour réussir oui
non j'ai accroché pour réussir non
franchement j'ai pas accroché j'ai pas
dis jamais personne n'a décoché jamais
jamais nous mettez vous l'avez fait
naturellement quoi way
par contre si je réussis alors là c'est
jeu pourrait cocher beaucoup ça vous
fait quoi je suis fou de vous voir dans
un film sur votre premier match du jour
leur dise oh oui comme ça mais mais
attends c'est normal c'est la première
fois que tu viens tout le monde en parle
jc mairie je joue si votre premier film
qui vous fait quoi de vous retrouver
dans un film
bon franchement je te jure quand j'ai
fait la première fois au cinéma je
disais c'est quand même quelque chose
d'incroyable de temps soit le cinéma tu
vois pas tête qui bouge toi même à moi
même je me regarde
bon je sais pas comment quelqu'un qui
aime trop dessus voir je m'appuie birgy
matin midi et a alors fait c'est la
dégringolade là j'en ai bien peur à
l'espace b c c'est quoi l'histoire le
film raconte votre vie d'une certaine
façon arrête de rigoler 1
celui ci tenait à 1,4440 coach et l'épée
de damoclès à
[Applaudissements]
non j'aime pas trop sinon je veux parler
sérieusement j'aime pas les yeux mais
impose sur la table je n'aime pas les
gens qui se moquent et je suis sûr
qu'ils pointent du doigt moi je réagis
tu aimes bien j'ai pas envie qu'on me
souviens de respectueux satan les stands
mais ça va on est pas on n'est pas en
pièces oui je suis ce film ça parle de
quoi ça raconte votre vie ça raconte ma
vie c'est un hommage à ma vie que je
suis venu du maghrib xj6 de m'intégrer
que j'ai rencontré l'amour j'ai assez
même à mon ex qui alerta de manière tout
à fait libérale parce qu'on m'a pointé
du doigt j'y suis ici d'une culture au
losc c'est l'état est quand même un
tabou laisse tomber je vous le fais pas
dire
vas-y souilah regarde pas mais j'ai dit
attention je dis attention les gens
surtout dans une période en ce moment du
christ ou le monde cynique le monde est
ironique il faut de la cohérence non il
faut du droit à la différence et me faut
un troisième mois en france la merci
beaucoup
cet été
et votre amant dans le film alain chabat
c'est un bon coup c'est beaucoup
oh ça va battre un bon koboko bon je
peux pas dire c'est un bon coup même si
j'ai vécu des choses est sur la place
publique je peux pas me battre de façon
si film et maintenant c'est filmé mais
mais quand même elle embrasse quand même
de manière à maule et à kyushu avec les
moustaches barbes rousses pas cet été et
est ce que depuis le tournage du film
vous n'êtes pas un petit peu jalouse
d'ophélie winter
non parce que ben moi je le vois la
journée ouais mais je crois à la voile a
nourri tant que stan équilibre au moins
tant moi même je n'ai pas très jalouse
de la félibrée hunter parce que j'ai eu
moi-même je chante
oui moi même ceux capables d'envoûter
des mélopées à n'importe quelles
conséquences
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas jaloux du
talent des autres je peux moi-même pour
une occasion de préciser ou même
aléatoire me laisser aller à la musique
à leur attention
faux
alors maintenant show une question très
importante et comme vous êtes devenu une
star vous opposer souvent des comme ça
si brad pitt vous proposer de faire un
film avec lui
est-ce que vous accepteriez brad est que
ces questionnaires brad pitt
brad pitt déjà j'aime pas trop si alors
un brad pitt
très franchement je vivrai oui moi je ne
sais pas parce que ça va être brad pe
john deere on est que les sketchs que je
connais personnellement et aux avis des
acteurs que vous connaissez pas moi ce
qui est important c'est le scénario
ouais c'est la situation dans laquelle
on va me mettre d'accord et
contrairement à beaucoup d'actrices
françaises qui va commencer à vous
prendre la tête avec les personnages de
ça ouais c'est aussi l'implication
personnelle que je vais faire et
j'aimerais mettre un autre point sur la
table car depuis quelques temps je suis
devenu intermédiaire du spectacle ah bon
des problèmes maintenant julien
j'aimerais mettre au grand jour et sur
la place publique des problèmes que
vivent les intermédiaires des spectacles
qui sont très importants en tant
qu'intermédiaire des spectacles je
trouve que c'est pas normal et loin de
moi un discours qui va dire pourquoi on
donne toujours aux maghrébins des rôles
de maghrébins n'ont manqué ce thion
c'est pourquoi tout le temps dit rôle
des femmes
on y donne aux femmes arrivent et
l'ironie sommes en étant nous sommes
est ce que vous voulez lancer un appel à
deux caméras vous regardez votre caméra
j'ai vu l'hôtel appel contre pas prendre
par exemple les femmes connues comme
huit femmes oui par exemple propre mais
pas menée sur 1 alors qu'ils auraient pu
prendre cette femme et voilà encore
closer clou de la lauch qu'est ce
qu'elle fait elle va faire un homme et
une femme à qui les budgets nationaux
trois hommes un coffret qu'est-ce
qu'elle après un coffret 3 andré ben
beau jour l'imagination des plats france
de tomber à temps je joue
cuz et moi oui si si il ya un seul film
vraiment qui a fait preuve de tolérance
dans le cinéma c'est beethoven car ils
ont pris un chien ah oui ce jeu vous
arriver
vous arrivez de mme agrebi est-ce que
c'est difficile d'être homosexuel dans
votre pays chouchou et bien entendu
alors la laisse tomber les gens vous
juge vous regarde vous montre du doigt
un ça dépend du qu'elle sait c'est pas
demain cc c'est pas demain qu'on aura
une une gay pride à marrakech quoi nita
craque et en slip tort moi je sais pas
moi non je pense pas franchement non je
ne pense pas pour l'instant il faut un
épanouissement encore beaucoup plus
important qu'un non pas pour l'instant
tu joues en tant que marocaine est ce
que vous êtes prête à partir en guerre
contre les pointes sèches et les cheveux
cassants
c'est elle qui suis honnête oui je parle
j'ai partir en guerre ben pas celle que
qui nous menacent la presse que si je
peux te dire que celle là alors la
laisse tomber
si dieu veut mais s'ils s'y prête à
partir en guerre pour les pointes sèches
qui suivent quatre sont toutes sortes de
combats la cellulite
alors là c'est pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
si vous aviez un mot à dire à tous les
travestis du monde ce soit chouchou ça
serait quoi
j'aimerais dire là vont me donner
l'occasion de pouvoir m'exprimer je suis
désolé des parce que vous m'avez touché
qu'on voudrait ça que j'aimerais qu'ils
vivent leur personnalité leur identité
comme ils veulent et que tous les gens
au monde qui ne regardent maintenant
qu'ils se sont différents eh ben ça fait
plaisir qu'il veut comme il veut
je joue
il disait l'un d'eux peut-être signer
mission de la rigolade c'est une
émission de temps en temps on est
capable de dire des choses très
sérieuses déjeuner est le message que
vous faites passer ce soir c'est un
message de de la gym bien votre mon
stage à l'espagne mais la gendarmerie
n'ont jamais fait de passer un message
de différence de tolérance du live
manque à mourens mais vive la france
vive la france
je joue qu'est-ce-qu'il plus dur
aujourd'hui c'est d'être une femme ou de
ne pas être une femme
je crois vous touchez un point très
délicat très sensible vous remuez
quelque part et chier moi des choses
très fortes
je crois que le plus dur c'est de ne pas
avoir est traîné comme une femme car
c'est un combat de tous les jours et par
un mois beaucoup de gens les tabous sont
là les gens vous jugent donc si de ne
pas être une femme qui est vraiment un
vrai combat
soit
[Applaudissements]
très émouvant je suis je crois que c'est
une séquence très émouvante mais ça sert
c'est un moment de télé hein y'a que sur
la télé qu'on peut avoir ça je choque at
il de plus féminin en vous du féminin
peut être bon pour parler sérieusement
et hamas ont scellé leur taille ouais
et peut-être des partis dits des parties
des deuxièmes parties de soirée
chouchou qu'y at il de plus masculin en
vaut toujours du plus masculin j'essaye
de le refouler
mais peut-être ce qui est du plus
masculin c'est ma détermination ma
motivation
et quand je dis quelque chose je peux te
dire qu'ils essaient komanda vous
entendez mieux que les hommes avec les
femmes avec des femmes
oui il n'y a pas de doute là dessus je
peux la comprendre
je lui ai conseillé mais je peux lui
donner des avis personnel je peux te l'a
retourné la tête en 10 secondes
un homme un homme si facile mais l'homme
est très manipulable
non contrairement et plus et les machos
et plus et dégonfler comme ça hein
les plus petits plus de m mais sauf
l'homme sensible attention donc sensible
intelligent l'homme qui l'a sensible des
prix qui sait devenir serbe est
exacerbée merci est ce que ça vous
manque que je suis fou de plus pouvoir
faire pipi debout
alors attention je contredis cette chose
car je ne vais pas y aller je veux pas
rentrer dans l'intimité
non je n'ai pas suivi encore avant mais
avec le cachet que j'ai perçu du cinéma
je ferai un voyage
dont les continents lointains si vous
étiez un homme chouchou quel genre de
femme vous attirerez madonna quand on a
pour moi c'est le comble de la sexualité
à outrance
ah ouais vous trouvez que c'est celle
qu'a l'air le plus [ __ ] quoi bon je
n'irai pas jusque là parce que j'ai dix
amis en algérie au maroc et me regarde
cette heure ci mais c'est une grosse ça
alors pas que j'aime bien je regardais
tous d'accord non non il n'y a pas de
discussions mais c'est agréable à
regarder c'est une grande artiste
je suis votre style d'homme c'est quoi
mon style d'homme c'est plutôt qu'on a
tu dirais daniel auteuil a way to steal
tuant qui conte un peu mystérieux qui
est pas trop exubérant même temps tu
sens très bien qui sait où il va c'est
qu'il est seul en ce moment daniel un
ballet s'élance moment pension ugolin
je savais capitaine
[Musique]
de bâton
m
on
[Musique]
trop
[Applaudissements]
dans
je t'emmènerai en riant
les beaux pays du monde
bord et la mort sans la plage ah ouais
je joue je suis tout seul
non
m
[Applaudissements]
le goût d'arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter tu joues
comment pourrais-je vous séduire vous
oui moi dit je suis très romantique
moi aussi alors bon j'adore renifleurs
jouer bas à lille et usurpe dit que les
mêmes aux as sauf les orchidées les or
qui dit c'est ma [ __ ] noir ça je touche
où vous faites quelque chose après
l'émission
tu sais quoi
ouais rendez vous rendez vous après les
meilleurs hu
[Applaudissements]
salah
là
j'aimerais vous décorer
[Musique]
du tout
[Applaudissements]
non ouais
excellent
[Musique]
neuf cents
ça
avant de recevoir mon invité suivant je
vous propose de revoir les meilleurs
moments de l'émission précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par monsieur jean yves
noël
[Musique]
n'étant serge on s'est vu tout à l'heure
ouais ouais bouge pas il un peu vexé
n'est pas le dossier sur cette actrice
voilà ce que les meilleurs dossiers
alors mellinet ce qu'on peut amener un
verre d'eau devant les honneurs comme ça
si vraiment il la gonfle hormis deux
mâles un bruit tu te prends ma version
sur la gueule
jusqu alors elle va premier des boules
puantes allait me mets dans un rapport
de metteur en scène et acteur je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres choses qui
rentrent en jeu je pense qu'on n'était
pas encore prêt à aller l'instant est
trop frais quoi il aurait fallu attendre
ils répondent aucune enseigne on
n'arriverait pas servir de le gérer le
célibataire là oui tu irais je suis
célibataire mais pas toi tu irais je
crois en l'amour je crois que je crois
dans couple je crois surtout dans la
famille je crois j'ai envie d'enfant et
j'ai envie de construire
voilà merci tout à fait il a toujours le
mot clic toujours facile à des
paillettes dans sa loge
bayer pour faire des enfants qui a tous
je sais
la vérité vous la savez vous je dirais
je la connais je pouvais pas le dire je
le savais où est partie le pognon des
frégates de taïwan je suis pas tombé
dernière année normale et si finalement
la relaxe en appel n'était pas tout
simplement qu'un renvoi d'ascenseur de
chirac à qui vous avez accordé
l'immunité
quand vous étiez encore président du
conseil constitutionnel
imaginez on peut faire un contrat du
genre je te protège tu protèges avec le
président de la république ça relève
quand même ou de la grande fantaisie ou
de la famille avant de ces types là ces
deux mises leur commune puisque salaire
comme ça d'être une sorte de graal
absolu n'est elle pas que leurs copines
achète un gode ceinture que e seul e
phase faire par leurs copines ça donne
égalité
le signe d un rapport d'égalité en fait
donc ça devrait aller sur un plateau de
télé depuis une minute il veut des
[ __ ] tout le monde
c'est pas ça je vois pas du tout où ils
soucis dans la symbolique
[ __ ] effectivement qui est important
c'est un artiste je viens gentiment
quand vous marchez avec des talons
aiguilles
c'est un peu précaire comme démarche
parce que non c'est parce qu'on en a on
a laissé faire on peut tomber facilement
on peut se casser les chevilles c'est en
même temps sinon je suis marché de
talent moi femme aimée marche et à l'an
passé un peu pervers dites moi mais la
perversité est un mythe inventé par les
bonnes jambes pour expliquer l'étrange
attraits de certains autres ça n'existe
pas la perversité
tout est dit
vous n'êtes plus belle en vrac sur la
photo on va merci pour se confier
moi j'aimais 5,2 à la photo et 5,8 en
vrai
moi ça me dérange pas la malhonnêteté
chez les gens donc bah je comprends vous
non mais
c'est pas du tout marie
sera détesté je voulais parler
aujourd'hui sais pas mais je sais pas du
tout ce que je voulais dire je ne
demande qu'à vous croire etc je vous
crois et puis je m'en tape un peu mais
sachez que même si vous avez été
malhonnête la tricherie et tout ça hier
affidés très beau film est très beau
livre le mensonge jusqu'où on peut aller
trop loin à cause d'un mensonge grâce à
un mensonge quand il est comme ça c'est
très bien
la véritable menace c'est effectivement
l'intégrisme chrétien chrétien qui a
pris le contrôle de la maison blanche et
qui a la main sur le bouton atomique et
qui se sert de la puissance militaire la
plus puissante du monde de manière
illégale
c'est là la première menace au monde ben
laden n'est pas l'ennemi public numéro
un c'est george w bush ya toutes les
chances pour que les américains
n'arrivent pas jusqu'à bagdad et se
trouve effectivement piégé là-bas à
l'ordre selon la doctrine militaire de
boucher bien nous aurions le droit
d'envoyer à ti tre donc préventif la
bombe atomique ce qui serait un
cauchemar
est ce que tu peux nous confirmer
qu'elle contre la guerre comme tout le
monde ici je suis absolument contre la
guerre je trouve qu'on ne le dit pas
assez
j'ai une chanson j'ai une chanson qui
cassent bien george bush
e
m
si vous étiez à pêcher l'avarice la
convoitise et toi te fare la gourmandise
[Musique]
y a pas de problème entre les hommes et
les femmes comme elle je vois je ne vois
pas d extraordinaire le geste a été
magnifique de sa part j'ai voulu boire
mon verre il était vide ses vues inverse
se poser la mairie où j'ai vu c'est sur
ce média
le regard que tu lui as fait m'attend
même moi qui suis pure et héros j'ai
craqué un petit peu
c'était tout le parler
la salle est une fête
non messieurs et s'est préparé par jean
dunand
et maintenant
voici gad elmaleh
[Applaudissements]
à
oui là messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
la mission
quel artiste un sas à cette chanson
c'est une chanson sur laquelle on a
dansé le smurf tout à fait bien sûr
c'est tout à fait l'époque bien sûr
c'est herbie hancock gaz
on
classé le chacha dessous c'est la
chanson du film que vous avez co écrit
gad elmaleh avec merzak allouache quel
réalisateur c'est ça tout à fait voilà
et avec chouchou dans le rôle principal
voilà exactement elle était là il ya
chez pai a dit me levais pas croiser en
coulisses oui je le croise en coulisses
on a parlé un peu et elle était un peu
ému parce que c'était la première fois
qu'elle faisait de l'année elle m'a dit
j'ai peur parce que tu sais ardisson
s'est toujours on sait pas trop ouais
mais j'aime beaucoup je suis sous - elle
nous attend tout à l'heure à la paix
calypso à la carte alors galles
c'est votre fer en fait qui vous a
présenté un un personnage de travestis
maghrébins à pigalle un soir j'ai
entendu la voix simplement je me suis
retourné j'ai vu une espèce de créature
hommes/femmes miami ouais mimolette
lâche un peu éprouvé chevalier base est
arrivé un truc très important la bar
mitzvah du petit azoulay oui exactement
j'ai fait un petit sketch mais c'est
normal vous étiez invité vous n'y avez
jamais l'émission mois pour tirer tout
le temps paraît tous les pas de souci
et donc c c'est un personnage qui m'a
troublé parce que c'était un mélange de
trucs de d'accent
d'accent que je connaissais bien accent
arabe avec un côté un peu efféminé
il y avait déjà un entre chaque de pas
mal de chose qui m'intéressait et ce
sketch est devenu un des phares de votre
spectacle offert je ne sais pas le code
phare dans le sens un clignotant de ma
carrière minute auxerre sera la place
clichy j'ai beaucoup de clients je leur
fais leurs fantasmes mais attends je
connais mes l'aimé pas
j'adore mobile et mais toujours en
gardant les pieds sur les épaules à
j'adore la nuit car la nuit pauli chat
noir on y voit pas
j'adore l'aiment
oh bien je prends mon bain j'adore lubin
aussi je prends mamba comme j'ai pas les
moyens m'engage les tourbillons mois nan
je prends mamba après j'ai bien détendu
tout ça pour aller à la paix quel est ce
jeu mais une belle robe échancrée
décolleté au collier d'hémorroïdes ici
partir à j'adore la peinture en gîte du
style que je préfère le plus dans la
peinture s'il l'impressionnisme et le
crépi chouchou dans le spectacle de gad
elmaleh il s'appelle la vie normale
retrouvez le sur dvd vhs mesdames
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors gâte c'est en ami à vous donc
merzak allouache qui vous avait déjà
dirigé dans salut cousin en 95 qui vous
a convaincu de faire un film à partir de
ce personnage de chouchou exactement
avec vous gal elmaleh alain chabat
claude brasseur catherine frot roschdy
zem et arié elmaleh exacte et votre
frère c'est mon jeune frère il génial on
va les salles et parfaire lui aussi les
biens pour faire des [ __ ] à cette
famille si tu peux être content mes
parents j'ai dit non non mon père
travailleuses et à la pop elle fait
toute la nuit tout saluer les vieilles
machines quand il change il est vraiment
bien alors le pitch
c'est l'histoire d'un jeune immigré
maghrébins qui s'appelle chouchou taddei
d'habitude ya je le fais vous le faites
je le fait qu'il est vous le fais tu le
fais le fait qu'il fait alors le pitch
et un jeunes immigrés maghrébins et des
comment vous savez tout ça mais je sais
pas comment c'est simple je fais
la berjallie milieu maghrébin il
s'appelle chouchou qui débarque en
france déguisé en réfugiés chiliens way
avec le pont de soda et puis le bonnet
d'intermittents du spectacle comme ça
ils fui la dictature de pinochet et il
trouve refuge chez un prêtre qui
s'appelle le père léon et qui joué par
claude brasseur club racer au curé faut
aller le voir aussi savent aussi et
alors le sacristain du père léon de
claude brasseur ses rushs dizaine
absolument extraordinaire frère jean
aussi un personnage et les croix en bois
comme ça il a des îles à des shorts de
scouts une extraordinaire jeudi on n'a
jamais vu comme ça jamais jamais alors
vous avez dit un truc au sujet de la
religion cathodique vous avez dit le
catholicisme est une religion
extrêmement ouverte dans une église on
peut entrer s'asseoir ce qui est un peu
si dans une synagogue une mosquée ou un
temple bouddhiste
je vous remercie ben c'est vraiment nous
minorités opprimées les catholiques bien
sûr ce que j'ai dit c'est que en effet
on peut tourner sans problème dans une
église là est tournée non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un endroit où on peut y
aller en tout cas pour se recueillir et
d'accords être tranquille il n'y a aucun
problème c'est plutôt bien je trouvais
plutôt bien merci pour nous donc en sus
du parc on est toute l'histoire mais un
jour il va à paris il rencontre alain
chabat que la tour maubourg pourquoi une
pensée des noms comme ça bah oui parce
que en fait moi ce qui m'éclate et
c'était de penser que chouchou crois
aussi que lui aussi il a un nom à
particule qui l'appelle chouchou de la
place tu que l'essai
shabana reste aux français faut le voir
aussi à plein de trucs à voir dans ce
film mais il est extraordinairement
juste alors il est où chaque jour
extraordinaire c'est à chaque fois il
est juste et on regarde même à quoi ça
ressemble magnéto serge dispard à qui
l'association de solidarité dès qu'on
est excellent a dit actuelle et de
l'amérique latine à stec je verrais bien
je crois quoi aulas tu quoi ton nom
je m'appelle choo choo choo choo choo
stanislas de la tour maubourg sochaux la
place clichy ce jour j'ai besoin aussi
d'un bon champ centre quels types de
cheveux cheveux ça oui moi de côté tout
est là mais si je suis bon j'adore elie
fleurs je pense pas mais il soutient
famille
[Musique]
et
le docteur est pas là aujourd'hui et si
tu veux travailler avec nous y'a pas de
problème tu m'écoutes monsieur quand je
te parle
non l'entraîneuse non non non ça fait
longtemps j'ai pas fait d'entraînement
as tu prends des cours prend des cours
du soir je voudrais présenter mes
parents c'est exactement comme je
l'imaginais ben oui ce stade nous a dit
que vous étiez dans la psychanalyse tuân
homosexuel refoulé je comprends rien
action vous dis que là tu veux [ __ ] le
commissaire fait moi qui vais te [ __ ]
pas de mitri à la salle et je suis dans
une merde internationale
je suis poursuivi peut pas rester s'il
ya trop de suspense
[Musique]
j'adore les chercher tu sais quoi
vraiment je m'applique docteur
croatie bien si tu regardes ap de la
rose
jamais je suis ou
le monde
alors ce que j'ai dit à gad c'est qu'au
delà de la dimension comique du film
j'ai trouvé excellent et en plus de ça à
certains moments réellement troublant et
ça c'est fort parce qu'à un moment on
oublie que vous êtes un garçon vraiment
on vous regarde comme une fille alors
vous vous entraînez la non la promo sur
l'été pouvant table en ce moment au
départ ça m'embête je vais pas me
plaindre de ça mais je ne fais pas
partie des acteurs français de ma
génération qui disent que [ __ ] faut
pas faire de trop bolat et des
snowboards fabresse moi ça m'intéresse
pas au contraire non sans oublier leur a
dit l'allemand
12 est quand même allé gagner le bol est
un artiste de dimension internationale
de l'admission il a commencé sa carrière
au québec
pratiquement aux états unis on pourrait
dire que c'est pas loin il y avait même
pas si ça ce n'est pas 6 1 2 une heure
d'avion mais comme je n'ai pas d'argent
à l'époque c'était et donc il a été
élevé dans le spectacle
et
ce soir
oui
et voilà alors je vais vous faire un peu
une question de journaliste comme ça
tout à fait un an que je vous la pose et
d'apprécier en place un gros boulot
quand mam épilation rasage la gaine pour
le ventre plat les faux seins la
perruque les talons aiguilles le
maquillage dur d'être une femme gad
elmaleh oui en même temps je pense que
depuis ce film là les fermes ont toute
mon admiration
je pense que la femme ne se résume pas
non plus à
des apparats physique à des espèces de
petites modifications techniques je
crois que la femme est dans cette
sensibilité une prédisposition à les
mémoires mais si vous êtes fait épiler
mais tous complets non pas que pas
complète papa le pas le maillot pas le
maillot juste le maillot diable alors
c'est dur d'être une femme sauf quand
c'est vous qui fait l'homme voilà parce
qu'alors j'ai lu dans paris match
un article formidable quand on lit ce
papier on a envie de devenir excusez moi
votre maîtresse j'aime le couple qui
fait ensemble voyager ensemble faire
péter un costard aller au resto aller
acheter des pompes qui fait la lie
ce qui veut dire en français prise et la
vie arrivé dans un palace se voir offrir
une suite mettre le peignoir ne pas
caché sa joie je vais vous dire une
chose très sincèrement avec la notoriété
il nous arrive des trucs
moi ça me fait des fois sourire et
rigoler et je le kiffe
j'essaye de la jouer genre pas trop
impressionné devant les mecs mais c'est
génial quoi tu réservé une chambre
normale dans un hôtel on te dit monsieur
el maleh nous vous avons pris une suite
royale monsieur elmaleh la suite royale
si vous voulez bien me suivre mais moi
je suis super content je vais je les
rends le peignoir les chaussons suis à
fond ça ouvre le rideau jeudi à ma meuf
je me suis pas fou dit ta gueule
non c'est vrai je dois dire dire que le
gall pour une grossesse c'est quand même
un bonheur ce qu'il aime c'est lui faire
des surprises
lajoux et romantique et puis alors très
possessif et ça les femmes adorent ça
qu'on soit possible s'il faisait qu'à sa
personne qui est possessif aujourd'hui
mois la petite séparation qui vous est
un couple ça me convient pas du tout
voilà donc en pique un bon le break
ouais c'est pas pour le break maintenant
je peux à terme à soin des yeux loin du
coeur même temps bref un mot maman faut
le savoir
alors vous avez beaucoup de succès avec
les jolies femmes 1
oui c'est vrai que
ge est un vrai bourreau des coeurs non
ça je ne sais pas enfin je nations là on
a des images mais rend pas bien compte
des images ah bon
[Musique]
gales oui être ou à cet instant précis
là maintenant tout de suite tout de
suite là franchement franchement
sérieusement sérieusement sans vous sans
vous offenser jamais en train de
regarder la télé tout le monde en parle
tranquille dans mon lien avec ma meuf
avec un bon un bon signe à la garde et
gad elmaleh à la télé ça vous plairait
non pas me regarder maintenant regarder
un documentaire animalier cette gazelle
qui vit au fond de la banda seul un cas
ni on a ça gala les i dans le mail qu'il
n'y avait que des mâles non en fait les
femelles étaient trop large ou arrêter
ça me rappelle les tournées
révisez les envie d'embrasser coûts qui
vaudraient n'en attendait s'il vous
plaît c'est vraiment brasser une
personne de sexe quel qu'il soit oui
alors là j'entends drame embarqué dans
un truc tu sais pas comment tu vas t'en
sortir eh bien il faut m'aider il faut
faire quelque chose
non
et mes parents thériault miguel ma vie
ex à la
ça
on
thomas
gad la ruche c'est vrai les meilleurs
moments tu ne fasses maintenant je vais
voir si vous êtes fidèles gad elmaleh
voici comment les mcr corps voilà
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
ma chance c'est normal
enfin votre connaissance de gad elmaleh
c'est un de nos plus grands artistes
français gagne sa vie tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il était la femme il était sorti
en vraiment j'ai adoré en fait je pense
qu'ils pourraient être meilleurs top
model que moi j'avais l'impression
qu'ils essayent le jaune et le violet
tissu on n'avait pas besoin de moi c'est
excellent c'était juste pour un rôle
mais je suis vraiment un homme je
voulais vous le dire
bien donc carolina vous venez d'avoir 19
ans le 28 février 2003 dire que vous
êtes né en 1984 à des chiens
à l'époque c'était la tchécoslovaquie
alors quand vous étiez enfant vous avais
jamais pensé être mannequin votre rêve
c'était de devenir princesse est en fait
exacts mais pose parce que lorsque je
terrain qu'il faut penser que j'avais
l'air d'un garçon j'avais des cheveux
très courts je regardais j'avais perdu
une fille je n'en avais pas de boucles
d'oreilles et gérer l'air d'un garçon à
la main et moi finalement mon rêve
c'était d'avoir les chieuses l'on est
d'être une princesse c'est bien réussi
maintenant je trouve c'est beaucoup
mieux mais c'est vrai quand vous étiez
adolescent vous aviez l'air au mas vous
étiez toujours anti third et guingamp
des et les garçons se moquer de vous à
l'école les fils mon âge qui a tué 13
ans 14 en trois ans j'étais plus
directement la moi non moi j'étais très
maigre j'étais très grande
je suis désolé je ne sais plus ce que
dit vous êtes vous étiez sur le point de
donner votre numéro de portable
jusque là
vous êtes des hommes super sympa très
beau et très gros n'a pas finalement
[Applaudissements]
d'accord c'est un combat à l'épée nous
le matin ça vraiment aller au duel en
duel à la première goutte de sang frais
vous deviez passe très bien
il fera bien venue de visites pékin
[Applaudissements]
je rampais lequel je suis autre
précédent caroline a été très moche
quand elle était jeune donc elle avait
les cheveux courts
elle avait les roma c'est l'été des
gants des les garçons se moquer d'elle à
l'école comme quoi faut pas désespérer
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de
vous inscrire dans une agence de
mannequins à prague
je ne suis pas vraiment inscrite dans
une agence de mannequins en fait ce qui
s'est passé et comment j'y suis arrivé
bien ce qu'un de mes amis il ne nous a
mis un prix une de mes photos à une
prime photo et l'envoyer en secret à
lagence et puis quelqu'un il m'a appelé
en disant un voile alors nous avons vu
votre photo et nous aimerions vous
rencontrer mais ça c'était le début et
puis ensuite je suis allé à new york
est ce que c'est vraiment commencé je
pense à un truc là on a déjà vu quand
même arriver valérie gauvin adriana
karembeu karolina kurkova
est-ce qu'on a encore beaucoup des
filles comme ça là bas parce qu'on
pourrait aller directement habiter en
dessous qui se maquillent j'en sais rien
compris à quoi il ya une fabrique de
bombes à sous poids la barre
bon alors vous arrivé à prague matière
carolina nous sommes prêts c'est pas
comme les filles de
comment s'appelle silicon valley
j'aimerais bien qu'on dise mamane ont
encore salé marseille états unis aucune
chance d'en baver si on traduit le passé
maintenant
elle a pas beaucoup rigolé à la paix
maintenant l'attenté des balkans tulle
et traduit après c'est toujours à new
york va bien alors c'est donc à trac que
le scout un scout c'est un type qui
cherchent des jolies filles dans les
pays de l'est c'est ça ou tu es un mec
un foulard ici est un béret sur le côté
c'est là que le scout alessandro band
sony vous découvre et vous emmène à
milan pour l'épauler collection il est
là les sandro ce soir bien sûr il est
derrière
10 absolument il regarde attentivement
je vais quand même comme dit si
alessandro est là parce que ça peut
changer complètement sûr c'était ce
qu'on commence à bosser ou pas
pourquoi est ce que ça change tout non
j'ai voté pour que ça change tout parce
que en fait c'est aussi votre petite
amie quand même non les young boys
alessandro is not
ouais
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on entend dans un jus fort je
sais pas comment dire ça tenait le mec
il a en coulisses c'est vraiment son
copain mais tout seul peut-être que
qu'il est mon petit ami et que je ne
veux pas en parler car ça il faut mentir
même les acteurs parfois et nantes vous
savez une hispano mérité tout il est là
ou pas elle a dit son prénom en anglais
ça m'a fait qu'il est à votre avis je
pense que non moi je pense je vais même
te d un peu il est sur ce plateau
à milan dont vous êtes lancé par
gianfranco ferré et très vite
d'incroyables à la carrière de caroline
a très vite vous défilé pour les plus
grands créateurs vous posé pour les plus
grands photographes
bientôt vous allez à new york et
attention à l'âge de 16 ans française
atos coach un last de 16 ans
carolina avait déjà gagné un million de
dollars ces gens là j'étais jeune
mannequin est la nature du réseau
glissant et oui ok la première mineurs à
faire la couverture de vogue usa
effectivement carolina et à 18 ans vous
avez reçu le prix du mannequin de
l'année on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
magnéto serge
[Musique]
d'ailleurs le seul
malheur
est-ce que
m
que faire
mama
[Musique]
car les messieurs alors maintenant je
peux vous le dire
carolina vous mesurer combien on cm
money un mais 80 comme moi donc on a
déjà 100 en commun ouais ouais m'enfin
on a quand même une silhouette un peu
différente
non je suis chez moi je suis maigre
c'est parce que vous voulez être voulez
être viré macho vous aimez les machos
j'aime bien les vrais hommes quoi toi
aussi à léo
mais ces travaux on va vous dites
carolina j'essaie de ne pas penser qu'à
l'argent vous avez beaucoup d'argent
[Musique]
j'ai cru l'argent ce n'est pas la chose
la plus importante dans la vie mais
c'est quelque chose d'important comme un
vieux pour pouvoir faire des choses
thomas nesbitt et folio spirit isabella
choses à plat
alliès isola 2000 et les poires karina
est ce que vous vous rappelez l'époque
où vous étiez pauvres riches oui mais
bon vivre avec classe moyenne normale
nous avions toujours de quoi nous
acheter à manger toujours de quoi nous
vêtir
alors pour voir son estrade où vous
n'aviez plus de succès on va faire une
inteview si j'étais peau karima carolina
dans quel pays habiteriez vous si vous
étiez pauvres et dames et en italie
est-ce que vous préféreriez habiter dans
un hôtel minable ou chez une copine
insupportable ya un super après c'est
juan question d'ici là tu parles
français à participer à mimer un petit
peu un bébé non je n'ai ni l'un ni
l'autre
quant à moi caroline à l'hôtel minable
et parce que je pourrais essayer de
l'embellir un peu jeu pour l'acheter des
choses pour décorer tandis que si je
vais vivre à quelqu'un que je ne
supporte pas peur des ondes négatives
alors là non ça ça ne plairait pas
carolina si vous étiez pauvres est ce
que vous mangeriez un jour sur deux ou
seulement à midi seulement à midi
boyer du vin rouge pour tenir le coup si
vous êtes ces pauvres non est ce que
vous seriez communiste si vous étiez
pauvres non plus est ce que vous auriez
peur des flics si vous étiez pauvres non
non
gad dans le temps les femmes laisser
tomber leurs mouchoirs
maintenant il reste un bel arrêt de
nouvelles actions j'essaie de voir kimi
qui va l'emporter pour le moment
personne s'est levé et ce n'est pas
tirée mais bon tir et si vous voulez
ramasser mon oreillette est ce que
pouvait l'acheter labat ainsi la est ce
que vous seriez capable de voler si vous
étiez pauvres si si je pense que
j'essaie arrêt d'une manière ou d'une
autre en faisant très attention
est-ce que vous vendriez de la drogue si
vous étiez pauvres est-ce que vous
accepteriez les avances de vieux
messieurs fortunés
non non si vous étiez pauvres c'est quoi
qui vous manquera le plus l'argent
et mon plan
n'est ce pas
mais si vasquez
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu l'arrêter
il a vu se vend la ffsa a été fait
c'est moins sûr
nous sommes
je parlais ce que tu dois faire avec le
pool s'appuyer sur cette touche enfin
est ce qu'on peut avoir un assistant oui
est ce que quelqu'un mais l'une voilà
mes lignes tu viens tu as plus là dessus
voilà sois gentil parce que moi il faut
que j'interviewe pas si on lâche ça fait
quoi
[Musique]
merci tu soulèves râle loi parce que moi
j'ai un truc ici qu'il gèle aussi bien
comment ça va
à main levée un look très classique
rejeté comme vous avez vous est
vachement bien karolina kurkova j'avais
lu mannequin de l'année je sais elle
fait tout les couvre de vogue us elle te
regarde on comprend pourquoi
quelle est elle est sympa et tout elle a
toutes les qualités 1
allez-vous lancer un petit peu vous
parler français bonjour ma belle série
très beau j'adore
alors vous publié chez albin michel un
livre qui s'appelle lentement place de
l'église pascal sevran
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le toit pour voir
mais faut l'aider c'est pas ça peut pas
rester comme ça sont des veaux faire
quelque chose peut-être maintenant
livrée avec mon livre ouais non pas le
vôtre et si oui et pardon non regarde le
doigt tant pis tant pis mais l'islam et
ça me fait beaucoup rire bien alors ce
livre rentrer en place de l'église
c'est le quatrième volet d'un journal
que vous avez commencé avec la vie sans
lui
deux cent mille exemplaires chacun ce
qui fait huit cent mille week-end à
cannes alors huit cent mille exemplaires
pascal sevran ça fait beaucoup d'argent
non oui mais ça fait beaucoup d'impôts
d'accord enfin vous avez quoi vous avez
quand même 15 20 francs par exemplaire
non j'ai pas demandé faudrait que je
leur demande
vous parlez en france vous êtes comme
moi vous êtes à peu rétro mon cher
thierry fumoir être au goût je vais pas
tourner en rond non mais maintenant
seriez vous avez les moyens d'arrêter la
télé ou pour y arrêter de faire de la
télé là vous aussi non non moi j'ai pas
encore près de faire noter les noms je
disais ça parce que ça vous aurait
permis de sortir de votre schizophrénie
pascal sevran
à un moment dans votre livre lentement
place de l'église où vous êtes dans un
village de la france profonde
morterolles votre fameux morterolles
vous êtes dans le silence depuis huit
jours est en train d'écrire
et puis vous vous regarder chanter
danser à la télévision et et vous dites
le décalage entre mon personnage public
et moi est incompréhensible c'est
qu'avant vous reconnaissez pas sur
l'écran vous parlez de gouffre entre
l'homme des lumières est l'homme de
l'ombre celui de morterolles et il vous
dit à un moment c'était car tellement
deviendra insupportable
j'aime beaucoup la chanson donc je ne
renie pas du tout l'homme un peu
enthousiaste l'accordéon les vestes de
tintin ça fait rien et bien c'est moi
aussi abandonné un homme se rassemblent
au fil du temps je ne renie rien de cela
mais est évident que quand je suis dans
mes province un petit peu comme ça
enfermé dans l'écriture qui compte aussi
beaucoup pour moi et dans le silence je
me regardais jeudi c'est
incompréhensible mon père ne comprenait
pas nombreux alors il ya deux pascal
sevran accueilli deux sèvres dans le
parisien un monde a un qui va dans les
restaurants qui s'annonce
un peu comme vous alors ça un peu sur
tout le monde les propos mouillé d'acide
quoi alors il ya le pascal sevran
parisien et puis elle morte héros les
oies comment je pense comment on dit
d'ailleurs
ouais j'en sais rien c'est joli le nom
morterolles démarche euros hl c'est beau
c'est joli ça chante un peu cei à mort
deux ans mais profite mais tout à fait
il ya le reste très triste et très oui
ça m'a beaucoup frappé le mot mort dans
morterolles pour des raisons que vous
imaginez et là où ils sont moins comme
art europe viennent même pas dire c'est
tout nord mon cher vous la porte
d'orléans
pour vous c'est la province franchir
willems éléments donc morterolles 7 au
nord de la haute-vienne voilà voilà
au nord de la haute-vienne images il
cela seulement savaient pas perdre il
faut trois ans pour revenir
non c'est vrai nom alors le mortirolo
zouaoui d'accord au niveau et muret
comme ça dans dans le silence dans la
douleur bah oui si c'est si vos deux
faces vous êtes vous êtes un janus c'est
du pipeau capable fils bien et vous
pascal sevran d'ailleurs sont aussi
réactionnaire dunks l'autre traînait
autour on pourrait dire vous avez la
nostalgie comme ça d'une france où les
oulémas son mason ou les jardiniers
jarny l'esam tricote c'est partir du bon
on a expliqué très agacé par l'histoire
de l'éducation nationale on a expliqué
que tu les jeunes gens devaient avoir le
bac absolument clair au fond qu'on a
absolument dévaloriser les vrais métiers
je vois qu'en effet les et les
techniques modernes l'ordinateur serait
très important sauf qu'on a fait des
générations de chômeurs et un jour là
médias nicole notât pourquoi ne
parlez-vous jamais l'apprentissage
almadies être femme charmante amy c'est
démodé mais j'ai trouvé que c'était pas
possible de dire cela et l'idée
imbéciles qu'il faille aller à l'école
jusqu'à 32 ans le bac + 40 de chômeurs
paraît ridicule
je crois qu'il ne faut pas décourager
les garçons et les filles qui veulent
faire des métiers magnifique comme seul
comme ce que j'évoque là c'est pas une
nostalgie mais la vie de tous les jours
tous les jours on a besoin de maçons de
plombiers etc
je trouve que cette sorte de folie qui
s'est emparée des ministres successifs
et surtout ceux de gauche
comme quoi il fallait à l'école a défini
mon pour une faire une génération
d'abrutis ça ne me plaît pas voilà et
alors il ya un truc qui vous
digne cd et boueuse ce que je veux dire
c'est que j'ai une très haute idée de la
femme et je n'aime pas quand elle
s'abaisse à notre niveau
soulève gm et assistance en clair
maintenant en vous regrettez les maisons
de correction
8 il faut dresser les garçons c'est leur
fait du bien c'est un fantasme que vous
avez à jeudi non je trouve que c'est
bien un petit peu d'ordre et un peu
l'éducation c'est pas mal je n'ai
beaucoup aimé cela il appelait
magnifique là dessus c'est pas mal si on
veut trouver un jeune et par siècle
ça serait pas mal et on voit peut
dresser les garçons oui c'est pas mal
vous regrettez par exemple qu'il n'y ait
plus que des écoles mixtes vont
regretter l'époque où les gars sont
montés sur monté sur le mur aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les filles se font violer
dans les chiottes des lycées c'est moi
je trouve que c'est pas possible non
plus je trouve que on le voit ça se
passe très mal
il faut un temps pour tout je vois qu'un
reportage l'autre jour je crois sur
france 2 dans sur les écoles aux états
unis commença à séparer un jour les
filles et les garçons se retrouveront
quand il le faudra mais je trouve que ça
n'est pas possible et et s'ouvre et là
je suis absolument sérieux il se passe
des choses pas possible dans les écoles
les enfants c'est très dur l'enfance et
les garçons des gens stress castagnet
les filles sont au milieu c'est pas
possible c'est une grande connerie de
giscard d'estaing voté par la gauche
il faut pas faire le mixité à l'école
voilà gad
je suis pour la mixité à l'école vous
êtes sur le même site et les courants
pas comme tout le monde évidemment
c'était moi je suis pas comme tout le
monde a son sens je ne serai pas habité
par vous ce soir vous regretté pascal
sevran vous regrettez les bordels
ça vous senti aucun et là je vais le
rejoindre c'est à dire que c'est à dire
que soyons deux secondes sérieux là
dessus l'hypocrisie qui consiste à dire
qu'il faut réduire la prostitution est
grotesque il faut respecter ces femmes
et ces hommes qui donnent leur corps
comme d'autres donnent leur esprit il ne
faut pas les mépriser
il faut mettre en prison et pendre les
proxénètes et faire les choses joliment
une très belle littérature sur sur les
maisons ça peut être très bien on peut
surveiller cela que les femmes ne soient
pas battus humiliés torturés
ce qui est scandaleux en conséquence de
quoi celles qui ont choisi sans aucune
contrainte de donner leur corps et il ya
des hommes qui ont besoin de cela on ne
peut pas être hypocrite sur ce sujet
c'est insupportable
donc je dis qu'il faut pendre tous les
proxénètes protéger les filles et les
garçons qui souhaitent faire offrande de
leur corps pourquoi moi je veux
apprendre du peu de talent que j'ai avec
ma plume
chacun a le sien je n'ai pas envie de
rire de cela c'est très grave et très
sérieux et oui en effet il faut
organiser la prostitue d'accord joliment
souvent nos produits novateurs l'axé oui
à l'époque où il y avait des bordels et
des bordels de garçons y avait des
garçons mais bordel systémique chez
fayard un petit peu c'est moins demandés
ouais mais se demander comment organiser
ça tout ça est très gentil le commerce
du corps est une chose très joli quand
elle n'est pas contrainte soit il faut
de tout les pouvoirs publics doivent
s'occuper en priorité de s'occuper des
salopards qui abusent des femmes
ouais hein ça on doit s'en occuper et
pour le reste les femmes et les jeunes
gens font ce qu'ils veulent de leur
corps alors quand on regarde votre
bouquin quand on regarde la couverture
vas-y zoom zoom bon garçon il ya un
petit village comme ça qui rappelle la
fiche pétainiste de françois mitterrand
la force tranquille et on pense un peu à
la france moisie dont parlait philippe
sollers dans le monde mais philippe
soler dit beaucoup de bêtises
oui la france moisie moi je ne trouve
pas six mois zik cela s'est beaucoup de
mépris pour les gens qui l'habitent
je ne dis moi je suis assez misanthrope
vous l'avez noté tout à leur jeu
aussi dira pas que la france soit voici
qu'est ce que c'est que ces termes un
peu vulgaire pour décrire les gt et la
famille 12 et vient c'est une france non
mais seigneur de france moisie sais tu
disais qu'on tirait salopards parce
qu'il n'ya pas de françoise y croire
monsieur sollers à des fantasmes et une
france un peu pétainiste comme ça c'est
ce que ces vieux mons à 9h et écouté mon
cher thierry vous êtes trop cultivé en
politique pour savoir que la france
pétainiste était gaulliste
trois ans plus tard oui oui d'accord
mais enfin il a été à l'époque péter
c'est la même
oui d'accord savait d'ailleurs alors
alors alors quoi non mais c'est
incroyable non mais c'est pas votre
mentor c'est emmanuel berl d'accord bien
est un grand philosophe il est
tranquille quand même et puis les
discours de pétain écrit la terre elle
ne ment pas je hais les mensonges qui
nous ont fait tant de mal vous le dit
très bien c'est très agréable et
baisseront langue française
les discours du maréchal pétain qui
était alors le vainqueur de verdun qu'il
avait promulgué aucune loi scélérate qui
l'a promulgué deux ans plus tard à vichy
et emmanuel berl qui était la conscience
du siècle le grand philosophe juif quand
on lui a demandé de réécrire aura été en
français les discours du maréchal pétain
a cru bien faire
à l'époque il wright est les discours du
vainqueur de vernouillet oui enfin vous
raconter dans votre bouquin c'est pas un
secret que je dévoile pascal vous
raconter dans votre bouquin qu'à la fin
des dîners chez vous ça vous plaît
maintenant les déchets me souviens des
russes
il chante maréchal nous voilà c'est très
amusant jeu s'amuse on comprenait g et
vous comprenez il ya des gens qui
savaient pas rire du tout quand même des
gens fous quand leurs parents des
dangers dans des camps de concentration
je souhaite vous que tu chantier
maréchal nous eh bien moi je sais c'est
normal que ça fasse pas rire certaines
personnes ça vous amuse follement je le
sers les moyens en tout cas on s'est
beaucoup amusé roule fait acier mais
vous le métier dans un bout mais je ne
le gêne je ne je ne me prive de rien je
vous le dis ce que je voyais là je dois
dire
et puis je suis au tout tout soupçon ce
domaine oui j'ai passé ma jeunesse un
prêt d'emmanuel berl way dans le genre
antisémite c'est pas mal oui alors pas
de leçons là-dessus c'est quoi non moi
je crois que vous êtes en fait un vrai
mitterrandien
ça c'est vrai avec ce que ça de
socialistes et de pétainiste c'est à
dire une idée de la france une idée de
délai
de l'âme française bouzid péter ça va
vite moi je veux bien choses tout seul
me 1 pas partir comme ça dans ce
politiquement correct qui m'écoeure donc
je ne peux pas accepter cela oui gm et
françois mitterrand je les respecte et
je les dis je ne renierai pas ce que m'a
apporté cet homme même un même quand
vous avez appris qu'il était le pote de
bousquet que oui mais en la guerre il a
eu la francisque etc tout ça tout ça est
vrai par l'histoire vous faire parler
vous êtes très bon là dessus oubliez
tout ça quand il a déjeuné avec bousquet
il avait là bousquet venait d'avoir la
légion d'honneur qu'il a été remise par
un tribunal à la libération fait de
résistants et de grands juif qui avait
remis la légion d'honneur à bousquet je
suis fatigué de réalité cela est vrai
n'ont pas donné à papon alors bien alors
dans ces dîners vous raconter ça je
trouve ça extraordinaire
vous avez un jeu forcé leur prochain
dîner oui oui je vais vous vraiment
parce que vous avez un jeu que j'adore
c'est sa belle le jeu du qui est mort
c'est un jeu très spécial qui est morte
en jean très cultivé il y avait des pas
patrick besson et c'est tout à fait les
garçons là toute sa bande d'écrivains du
figaro ils sont très bons les et alors
on s'amuse beaucoup à ce qu'a écrit et
non c'est très bien on oublie défense
dit amélie justement claude autant lara
est ce qu'il est mais oui il est mort
gérard manset non enfin presque
gr messmer non
jean-jacques servan-schreiber non mais
pas mort noyé souffrent ils souffrent
raymond poulidor
non j'ai passé mon pays la haie à côté
chez moi andré stil alors andré stil
membres du jury de l'académie française
la jambe arrière parce que c'était le
prix lénine en symbiose faire un truc
extraordinaire et ma mère lisait dans
les journaux communistes les livre
d'andré style et je disais à besson
autre jour est ce qu'il est mort il m'a
dit non ouais alors votre journal rien
que vous et moi qui savais qu'ils
servent et non votre journal donc le
quatrième tome lentement en place de
l'église
trouvant tous les cas un truc c'est que
l'homosexualité vraiment entré dans les
moeurs c'est à dire que maintenant ça me
donne des idées
bah il
des dizaines de milliers de lecteurs qui
compatissent à la disparition de votre
ami stéphane sire que les les bonnes
femmes qui d'habitude lisent les
bouquins de arnie arnaud de madeleine
chapsal elles lisent votre bouquin le
fait que ce soit un garçon ça pose pas
de problème elle ne lis comme si c'est
une fille
donc ça prouve que l'homosexualité est
rentré dans les moeurs oui l'amour ne
pose pas de problème ouais et je m'en
doutais un peu j'en ai vu la
confirmation et voit ses questions à des
gens ne se pousse moi nous sommes des
pauvres gens des hommes et des femmes
brisées et qui passons notre vie à
courir après cela et l'amour emporte
tout en conséquence de quoi
heureusement dans ce monde dans lequel
nous vivons en france
et ça ça arrange beaucoup au pays et la
jeunesse n'est pas pour rien tout ça ne
pose pas question moi je n'ai jamais
posé cette question d'histoire de c'est
très peu important la sexualité la
sexualité c'est une affaire pour rigoler
ou pour faire des bébés
et encore le reste ça occupe assez peu
de temps dans la vie ce qui occupe
beaucoup de temps dans la vie c'est
l'amour est ce que retiennent les gens
qui veulent bien me lire
c'est la mort ou au delà de tout il
s'agit stéphane exactement ce que cela
me réconcilie un peu avec le genre
humain
mais c'est la première fois qu'un livre
qui raconte comme ça un couple
homosexuel séparés par la mort à un
succès public aussi important oui voilà
ce que je voulais dire oui voilà
l'homosexualité est admise donc à l
inverse on reproche de plus en plus
souvent maintenant aux homosexuels leur
pouvoir monsieur c c'est ce que fait la
main avec le nouveau maire alain minc
travaille du chapeau on le sait depuis
longtemps oui il y aurait travaillé au
monde veut tout dire non mais c'est vrai
qu'à comme un pouvoir gay aujourd'hui
dans ce pays annonce avait bien non du
tout un banc quel pouvoir qu'est mon
beau garçon c'est grotesque quand on a
une énergie quand on a un petit talent
quel que soit conçoit écrivent à
garagiste chanteur hou hou hou plombier
est ce qu'on vous demande avec qui vous
coucher à cet invraisemblable on se
demande vous réparez vos tuyaux de
tuyauterie de baignoires et on ne pose
jamais la question vous ne vous demandez
pas si vos jardiniers ou votre chauffeur
taxi aime les filles les garçons nous a
pas de sens bien en tous les cas vous
dites dans votre livre que vous avez
jamais remplacer stéphane aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas de fiancé je crois qu'on
peut le dire
pascal un nom mais plusieurs oui oui
vous dites mais amants sont de passage
oui vous avez rien à redire après le
sexe dont vous préférez pas les voir là
vous préférez vous dites vous ennuie la
mosson contre on peut parler voilà on se
dit finalement je veux jouir et après
dîner avec des femmes qui lisent mes
livres c'est bien c'est ce que vous
dites oui c'est ce que je pense
oui car maintenant donc c'est juste le
sexe d'un côté et l'esprit de l'autre
série on ne cherche pas l'amour comme
les comme les champignons je veux dire
parfois on se défend la trappe des
champignons qu'on a vu ça j'ai entendu
ça quelque part je vous l'avais préparé
sur luge et de faire belle fille non
mais donc ça vous permet d'écrire la
tête l'ipsa c'est à dire qu'une fois que
vous avez fait l'amour disant peau ben
c'est commun c'est comme boire à peu
douay
c'est une chose amusante un instant bien
pascal qu'une importance vous savez
pascal qui est un grand classique dans
cette émission gars je vous regarde tout
le travail c'est l'alerté rose procès
l'interview à l'arthrose
alors on la parfaite depuis septembre
mais ce soir spécialement pour vous j'ai
ou faire l'interview alerte rose n'en
bleus
mais voilà les gars ont très bien tout à
fait un de chaque côté comme à l'époque
d'ailleurs toros voilà voilà
vous le connaissez quel succès vous êtes
très bien là bien alors pascal interview
verte bleue est ce que vous préférez
draguer ou vous faire draguer me faire
demander est ce qu'on veut faire
embrasser ou vous faire embrasser nous
faire embrasser caresser ou vous faire
caresser le faire car s arrête juin
début d'érection là puisqu'elle
si vous pouviez vous faire larguer
[Applaudissements]
largué vous préférez un mec qui bosse
bien mecha infidèles ou un mec qui
baisent mal mais qu'est fidèles un mec
qui baisent malbec et fidèles à aller
non c'est le contraire si votre
partenaire vous propose une partie à
trois vous préférez que ce soit une
fille ou un garçon
ah ça peut être amusant avec une fille
ouais comme quoi ça c'est déjà fait vous
préféreriez faire l'amour avec 1000 mec
toujours de la même façon
ou avec un mec mais de mille façons
différentes je peux obsédé par ça du
tout est d'accord ça n'amuse très peu de
temps oui bah je sais pas moi prenez du
viagra
bon cela très bien
merci aux garçons
[Applaudissements]
là
et maintenant
voici les chatons atomique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
là
les chatons atomique mesdames messieurs
gad elmaleh pascal sevran karolina
kurkova
alors on passait la présentation qui
élisent mcclaren you are les lots les
mois alors on vous appelle vous votre
chance et glitter kitten c'est à dire le
chaton glitter parce que je suis comme
un épi tout ce qui brille par exemple
votre brosse une solution pour ça ouais
alors vous mesurez un mètre soixante dix
est du signe du bélier je dis ça fait m
luc roy way est votre premier baiser
quand vous en parlez vous dites j'ai
trouvé ça mouille et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être avalés j'ai pensé à
une machine à laver le linge ou l'arrêt
le mec il avait une grosse langue qui
dormaient déjà ici connaît pas très bien
je ne savais pas à l'époque mais je sais
maintenant ce que sait faire
alors natacha dit tâche c'est vous allez
vous vous appelle partie keaton c'est à
dire là la petite chatte de la partie
de la jatte de soirée la tête et donc
vous mesurer à m 76 et du signe du
cancer est votre premier baiser vous
avez du mal à vous en rappelez vous
dites mon premier baiser je devais avoir
7 ans et à ce temps ça oui c'est ça j'ai
commencé très tôt vous savez et vous
avez continué après au moins la wii
jenny c'est vous 1 m 73 du signe du
poisson normal que vous soyez
végétarienne premier baiser assez rapide
non non non non pas si rapidement
abon cgt viennent je ne suis pas
végétarien de temps de jeu derrière
bah ça c'est un autre goût voilà j'étais
assise puis à dakar est ce que c'est
vrai que votre premier baiser était
assez rapide vous étiez caché dans un
coin comme ça pour pas être vu non c'est
la fiche d'une douzaine je me suis
l'oraison pas votre premier baiser gâte
vous vous en souvenez ouais ça me
rappelait une sécheuse
ah oui c'était pas une machine
une sécheuse zhang chi comment ça
est ce que vous savez qu'il ya des gens
qui font l'amour sur les sèche linge
il paraît pas poser à cause des
secousses d'un tremblement italien sur
trois qui fait l'amour sur un sèche
linge sur des statistiques parce que ça
nous concerne il s'agit plutôt d'un lave
linge en fait elle sait que c'est des
vrais ménagères vous vous souvenez de
votre évolution au pied de votre premier
baiser vous c'est dans la cour de
l'école je suis sûr oui à l'époque où
c'était pas à l'époque c'est pas mixtes
et lg d'embrasser les garçons 1
il est enfin arrivé sans suite le
premier baiser vous et vos sacs
c'était moi comme l est pas très bien
fait mouiller l'impression d'être avalé
comme ça très agréable comme impression
pas du tout je ne savais pas à l'époque
vous êtes vous êtes anglaise vous venez
du pays de tony blair
c'est un grand grand du pays de la bière
vous avez vu la télévision ce soir vous
avez ce qu'il est arrivé j'ai pas vu ce
soir ce qui s'était vraiment pas sinon
on a des images
ça en fait rire une les deux autres
elles sont très blairiste à mon avis oui
il y en a aussi des images de george
bush
c'était la qualité de la vie
internationale alors les chatons
atomique parce que c'est votre nom les
chatons atomique
le groupe a été fondé par deux anciens
de au mgi orchestral manoeuvres in the
dark
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et enola gay tu
te souviens des enola gay je veux
retrouver l'autre c'est le troisième
[Musique]
vous savez savez ce que ça veut dire
enola gay vous savez ce que c'est et
enola gay c'était le bombardier en fait
l'avion qui portaient la bombe
bravo la bombe de hiroshima les
américains donnent toujours des noms
alors bombardier enola gay des noms gay
quoi l'algérie remarquer cette semaine
une bombe qui s'appelle la mère de
toutes les bombes
ils se font sur des noms extraordinaire
pour le charmant bien alors on va parler
de vous maintenant très sérieusement les
filles vous êtes prête alors votre
premier single ça s'appelait wall again
deuxième c'était eternal flame
art you
m
[Musique]
et le troisième c'est détails
vous connaissez orlando orlando à
orlando
ils exigent le clip magnéto serge
[Musique]
aïe
là
[Musique]
non
ouais les châteaux atomique et le cd
s'appelle fils se brouille
[Musique]
et
quatre championnats vous allez prendre
l'autre à 10 ans maintenant
oui enfin bordeaux à bordeaux
aulas bordeaux demain mois pour la promo
du café maure des grands groupes tout ça
à bordeaux
ok fait qu'augurer station
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé au west et des filles à 3 je
suis sûr que c'était ici bien amusé et
est ce que l'on prenne un conseil et
maintenant
ah oui voici ce topic mathlouthi
[Musique]
bonsoir
alors toufik vous êtes né en 1956 à
kalaa kébira en tunisie vous êtes le
fils aîné de votre famille est l'unique
émigrés des neuf enfants
exact alors vous avez été élevé par un
père enseignant et qui était imam à la
mosquée de la zitouna en tunisie est ce
que votre père a eu de l'influencé sur
vous sur le plan religieux le fait qu'il
soit imams bien évidemment quand on est
élevé dans une famille traditionnelle
il y a toujours une influence ouais
alors vous arrivé en france en 1977 fait
des études de droit
ensuite vous travaillé dans un cabinet
d'avocats vous devenez ensuite
consultant pour des grands groupes comme
dhl air corse le port de marseille où
fonder un mensuel économique qui
s'appelle business coupe qui est un
mensuel bilingue en arabe et en et en
français vous montez votre première
radio rfc puis votre 2ème radio radio
méditerranée en 1992 et pied un jour en
mai dernier à la suite des massacres de
jénine en palestine
vous décidez de participer au boycott
des produits américains et vous décidé
de lancer un cola alors votre première
idée c'est d'importer en france un cola
qui existe déjà à l'étranger qui
s'appelle lausanne âmes colas qui a été
créée en iran par les par les mollahs
mais impossible d'obtenir quelqu'un au
téléphone
donc vous pouvez pas apporter le ramdam
cola et vous décidez de créer votre cola
alors là attention le csa m'autorise à
citer une fois le nom de votre produit
donc écoutez bien mesdames messieurs
parce que si ce nom et reprononcer il
sera à biper votre produit s'appelle le
mecca cola voilà et le csa c'est la loi
impose aussi de citer les noms de vos
deux concurrents pour une raison d'
équilibre dans vos deux concurrents sont
coca cola et pepsi cola
je sais c'est un peu ridicule mais c'est
comme ça
c'est le csa qui les oblige à faire ça
alors c'est un an génial évidemment cola
parce qu'en france quand on dit la
mecque
c'est effectivement on dit c'est la
mecque de la mode la mecque de la
chaussure la la la la mecque
il faut marche alors j'ai trouvé la
recette sur internet c'est fou ça qu'on
trouve la recette du cola sur internet
moi je restais un truc hyper secret qui
étaient détenus dans un coffre
atlanta il suffit d'aller sur internet
un open cola et vous avez toutes les
recettes que vous voulez ouais voilà peu
tous le faire on va la faire le chocolat
au lait chocolat parfaite accents
marqués alors pour la fabrication
finalement on s'est aperçu qu'en france
il y avait 22 fabricants de sodas et que
18 appartenait aux deux grands noms que
j'ai cité juste avant et un des derniers
indépendants donc accepté de faire
confiance devait emprunter 22000 euros
et vous avez commandé 160 mille
bouteilles et dix jours après tout était
vendu seulement même pas trois jours
après la rupture de stock recommande 320
mille bouteilles quatre jours après
rupture de stock
ouais donc je m'attendais pas du tout à
ce phénomène très sincèrement quand j'ai
vu la première quantité 160 mille
bouteilles se faisait une montagne et je
me suis dit ouh là là je crois que j'ai
fait une connerie
comment je vais faire écouler sas vais
m'asseoir dessus et boire pendant dix
ans devrait finalement c'est
c'est parti vous avez vendu quoi
aujourd'hui trois millions de bouteilles
c'est ça non ça augmente de jour en jour
je suis aujourd'hui à quatre millions et
demi de bouteilles et 14 millions de
bouteilles en fabrication
c'est un délire il a dû trouver
beauchamp pour gagner la sacoche
alors vous avez une bonne pub pepsi ne
buvait plus idiot buvait engagé oui
effectivement 1
alors c'est vrai tous les journaux et
toutes les télés de la planète vous ont
fait une énorme pub gratuite on a eu des
parler de vous dans tous les journaux
est votre recette en fait c'est un mix
parfait entre le marketing et le
militantisme pas ce que vous dites c'est
le premier produit anti impérialiste du
millénaire c'est un produit identitaire
c'est un drapeau anti américains
s'attendent moi votre produisons j'ai
cité de nom tout à l'heure on milite
c'est un geste militant
quand on achète une bouteille de notre
breuvage ce n'est pas un acte neutre
veut dire qu'on veut signifier à
l'administration américaine son
opposition à cette hégémonie à ce
bellicisme qui se confirme de jour en
jour 1 et donc c'est pour dire stop nous
aussi en existe et on veut plus donner
notre argent pour qu'ils financent
l'achat des f 16 ou de drones ou autre
chose pour aller bombarder
ils étaient tous fiers d'exhiber ya
quelques jours la plus grosse banque du
monde 9 la mère de toutes les bombes par
parodie de saddam hussein qui parlait de
la mère des batailles donc finalement
ils sont même niveau tous les deux et
c'est ça qui m'écoeure c'est que bush
qui veut combattre le terrorisme
finalement il est exactement identique à
ben laden est exactement identique à
saddam hussein ça n'engage que vous
une partie des bénéfices est donnée aux
enfants palestiniens 10% des bénéfices
seront reversés à des associations qui
aident l'enfance palestinienne mais pas
sous forme d'argent je loue ainsi c'est
très important
sous forme de dons en nature ça veut
dire soit des cartables des livres des
crayons des bus scolaires ou des
équipements des gaules mais uniquement
sous cette forme là alors sur votre
radio la radio méditerranée
vous passez votre temps quand même à
dénoncer le sionisme comme une idéologie
raciste et et vous souhaitez ouvertement
la disparition d'israël que vous appelez
d'ailleurs pas israël vous appelez
l'entité sioniste
je combats le sionisme effectivement
c'est une idéologie raciste
je rappelle tout de même qu'il était
inscrit ainsi sur les tablettes de loi
nuit jusqu'à la signature des accords
d'oslo
mais avant les accords d'oslo s'étaient
inscrits comme idéologie raciste
je ne vois pas ce qui a fait changer
particulièrement quand on voit sharon
aujourd'hui et ceux qui dirigent avec
lui qui sont partis des partis d'extrême
droite ça n'émeut personne l'extrême
droite gouverne dans l'entité sioniste
c'est tout à fait naturel c'est bien une
personne n'en parle wright en europe 1
attendez attendez donc si vous êtes
contre l'entité sioniste vous n'êtes pas
pour le remplacement de l'état d'israël
par des palestiniens à un état
palestinien mais pas arabe la nuance est
importante
un état palestinien quand porte des
juifs des chrétiens et des musulmans les
juifs où ils vivent quand même comment
ça pourrait vivre dix ans par rendement
ayant parfaitement le droit exactement
au même titre que les chrétiens et les
musulmans
c'est une terre des trois religions
monothéistes et chacun y a droit de vie
en paix et en parfaite coexistence
paisible
vous affirmez quand même sans arrêt sur
votre radio la radio méditerranée que
les médias français sont pro sioniste
alors quand j'entends toute la journée
d'hier qui sont pro palestiniens est
injuste parce que j'ai même rendu
hommage à votre émission à deux reprises
et à d'autres émissions je n'ai jamais
généraliser je me bats contre l'amalgamé
la généralisation donc je ne peux pas
compter moi j'ai lu dia le sang je sais
ce que vous avez déclaré maintenant
c'est peut-être pas envie de l'assumer
ce soir je l'assumé parfaitement je sais
que vous avez déclaré
dit que les médias français sont
pro-sionistes alors qu'on leur reproche
toujours d'être pro palestiniens vous
tapez sur des propagandistes sionistes
ce que vous appelez des propagandistes
sionistes
oui vous citer des noms ce que je ne
ferai pas moi parce que le dernier qu'il
l'a fait en france et le pen voulait
dénoncer
bah oui vous savez bien la main comparer
avec le pen c'est vraiment un peu hâlé
forêt dénoncé des genres ont dénoncé des
genres en dix ans est unique et alors on
se bat tous contre la pensée unique
nation 300 démocratie on a le droit
d'affirmer ses opinions même quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec le sionisme
alors vous aviez un parti politique je
sais pas où ça en est qui s'appelle le
parti de la france plurielle ça existe
toujours
toujours ce parti a quand même été co
éditeur d'un d'un livre beige vous
arrête tout de suite c'est faux et il ya
eu un démenti dans le quotidien le monde
il y a eu une usurpation de l'identité
du parti de la france plurielle dans ce
brûlot contre sharon qui a été édité par
trois personnes et le parti des
musulmans de france à strasbourg et je
n'avais aucune connaissance de cela je
l' ai découvert comme tout le public
avec le nom de mon parti donc c'est pas
faut donc c'est pas faux oui mais
regarde le nom de votre parti sur le
bouquin absolument donc c'est pas faux
ce oui j'aime me dire non mais ça
s'appelle le manifeste judéo nazis
d'ariel sharon ce qui est faux c'est de
la tribu et comme un acte voulu et
revendiquée par nous n'avons jamais je
veux bien vous croire je ne suis pas
qu'il ait pas de nom sur le livre je ne
me suis pas fait avoir ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle à vouloir mettre le nom
d'un parti sans l'autorisation de ses
adhérents lit de son président henri
bien est-ce que vous roulez ou non pour
les islamistes
absolument pas alors là vous pouvez
chercher puisque vous êtes bien
renseigné sur ma vie je suis plutôt mal
vu que bien vu par les islamistes
j'aurais du mal à être un islamiste je
suis musulman est tout à fait
naturellement comme d'autres se
réclament d'être chrétien ou juif c'est
un droit mais un tri cela mist bien au
contraire je suis trop amoureux de la
liberté et de la justice pour pouvoir
accepter d'être un islamiste
toufik mathlouthi pensez vous que ce
soit bien pour gagner de l'argent de
base une stratégie publicitaire sur la
haine des peuples
moi je boycotte les produits américains
pour lutter contre l'impérialisme
américain où est la haine là dedans je
boycotte la politique et
l'administration bush
je n'ai jamais condamner le peuple
américain ni cherché à attiser la moins
de rennes je crois qu'il faut pas
chercher la haine là où elle n'est pas
la haine elle est plutôt développé par
d'autres sur d'autres terrains c'est
votre droit rahim
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
pascal
mais quelque chose a ajouté je suis
évidemment pour beaucoup de raisons pour
le vis du peuple israélien et de l'état
d'israël sur pour que les palestiniens
soient traités dignement
mais évidemment je ne suis pas un
admirateur échevelé de monsieur sharon
peut-être c'est une façon différente de
le dire mais c'est exactement ce que je
pense je ne suis pas pour l'éviction du
peuple juif de cette terre bien au
contraire je ne suis pas non plus pour
une vie d'opprimer et de sacrifier pour
les enfants palestiniens le peuple pas
les seniors dans son ensemble je suis
pour que tous deux vivent y donne la
dignité
par contre je suis un farouche mais
alors un farouche ennemi de sharon et de
sa clique qui gouvernent aujourd'hui ce
discours n'est vraiment pas scandaleux
il est humain 4 pas encore fait de
parler de ça je ne sais pas moi je suis
invité en tant qu'artiste dans cette
émission pour parler de mon fils me
demande de réagir sur sur st moi je suis
tellement et à travers mon fils mais à
travers ma vie à travers l'éducation que
j'ai eu c'est à dire l'éducation que
j'ai eues dans la cohabitation
je dois voir moi je suis j'avais un
prénom juif un nom arabe oui moi je suis
né au maroc j'ai vécu au maroc dans la
vraie cohabitation
voilà un moment donné d'ailleurs
monsieur a parlé d' amalgame je suis
d'accord dans le sens où on peut tout à
fait être et c'est ce que je dis dans le
film encore une fois je parle du film
parce que je suis ici en tant qu'artiste
ce soir il y en a marre de prendre les
artistes à témoin chaque fois sur la
plupart ils avaient tous à 7 sur 7 chez
anne sinclair pouvait leur avis mais ça
n'existe plus et je crois qu'à un moment
donné on peut on la décrit dans le film
tout à fait pratique un judaïsme
tranquille en islam éclairé un
catholicisme comme père léon dans mon
film tout à fait cool voilà et c'est pas
démago ni naïf de se battre pour la paix
c'est ce que je sais pour ça que je pris
aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que je fais ce
métier là voilà
j'accueille quelqu'un qui n'est plus
choqué que gad et pascal par vos propos
voici gilles william goldnadel
aujourd'hui
gilles william goldnadel bonsoir vous
êtes avocat international président
d'avocats sans frontières vice président
de l'association france israël est votre
dernier livre publié le nouveau
bréviaire de la haine antisémitisme et
antisionisme
c'était chez ramsay
[Applaudissements]
alors ce extraordinaire de vous avoir en
face tous les deux parce que vous vous
dites que les médias français sont tenus
par les pro sionistes ils veulent nadel
souvent que vous exprimez vous dites
qu'en fait les médias français pro
palestinien
oui mais enfin je ne demande pas de
désert à bizet les médias français alors
que monsieur en face de moi a indiqué
qu'il voulait des sionisés la presse
française c'est tout de même un peu une
nuance importante il me semble je peux
vous répondre là dessus et vous avez
beaucoup parlé
vous avez beaucoup parlé vous avez
beaucoup parlé vous ne m'empêchait pas
de parler mais blanche veut d'abord
wengen parce que monsieur réalisé dans
la défense de la violence de la haine
c'est que vous allez m'empêcher de
parler va sûrement parce que vous pensez
un seul instant que vous allez
m'empêcher de parler franchement je n'ai
même pas envie de vous parler alors
c'est simple
j'en prends acte
on vous a raconté des histoires tout de
suite et vous dites que j'ai écrit le
nouveau pas vers de la haine donc je
sais un peu de quoi je parle
effectivement est ce que c'est vous êtes
l'avocat de la haine vous savez oui
donc lorsqu'on vous dit que on ne sait
pas où se trouve la haine moi je vais
vous dire où se trouve la haine d'abord
monsieur mathlouthi voix raconte des
histoires lorsqu'il dit qu'il n'a pas
mise en cause très gravement l'existence
même de l'état d'israël
en voulant sa destruction le 9 juin 2002
monsieur mathlouthi indique radio
méditerranée
parce que monsieur mathlouthi veulent
vendre de la limonade ça me dérange pas
du tout là où je veux mettre en
perspective sa vente de colas c'est
lorsqu'il exploite une radio qui
s'appelle radio méditerranée
véritablement une radio de haine qui
s'est d'ailleurs fait récemment taper
sur les doigts fois le csa faut bien
vous racontant voilà ce que c'est faux
vols entre viry voilà ce que dit le nord
c'est faux ce qu'il raconte la personne
jamais fait ça voilà 2002 monsieur matte
louis en parlant de l'entité sioniste
est d'ailleurs le journal le monde qui
n'est pas je pense un suppôt du sionisme
on dit qu'on ne l'ont pas d'excusés le
mandat que le titre indique le journal
le monde indique que vous avez à peu
près les mêmes positions que le ramasse
donc monsieur monsieur mathlouthi nous
indique le 9 juin 2002 en parlant
d'israël
cette présence n'a aucune légitimité
cette entité l'état d'israël n'a aucun
droit à l'existence
le 21 juin 2002 l'état d'israël est
appelée à disparaître
c'est un fait historique indéniable et
indiscutable l'état d'israël ne peut pas
exister
je vous indique que j'ai trouvé ça dans
un livre que je vous recommande qui
s'appelle les territoires perdus de la
république qui est un livre écrit par un
collectif de profs qui se plaint qui ne
sont pas des suppôts du sionisme et qui
se plaint de la menthe et de la montée
de l'antisémitisme dans les écoles parce
que bien entendu quand les gamins des
banlieues mais elle sur les jamais radio
méditerranée
vous imaginez ensuite ceux qui peuvent
se dire dans la cour du préau
ensuite en ce qui concerne la haine
propre roman dit monsieur et là je suis
désolé je suis dans une émission de
variétés pas du tout thierry la preuve
que non d'accord sur ce point là j'ai
pas envie de rire parce que le 1er juin
2001 j'étais en israël et j'étais à 100
mètres du delphinarium la discothèque où
vous avez eu 20 gamine qui ont été tuées
assassinées par le ramasse dans une
discothèque 16 enfants sont morts en
plein soleil par un missile de l'armée
israélienne et je peux avoir autant de
victimes bien vous il plus par non je
veux dire on va pas refaire le cuir on
vous a écouté la spéciale
il avait expliqué que vous achetiez un
homme formidable que vous m'avez ctif
effectivement nominalement sur la radio
voilà ce qu'odile trois jours ou si voix
la radio les voilà ce que dit le 3 juin
la radio méditerranée effectivement que
je cite dans mon livre il ya une
certaine nacira le 3 juin
voilà ce qu'elle dit à la radio que
mathlouthi le chantre de la paix oui
quand j'ai entendu à la radio qu'il y
avait la tente à tel-aviv
ça m'a fait plaisir j'appelle les
musulmans à agir
la seule solution c'est passer à
l'action générale il ya un intervenant
qui mène de la desert viana devrait pas
vous mais là il a été arrêté cette année
sur les fils et ses filles avaient cessé
d'opposer s'envole on prenne ses aises à
la suite de la cité des arts et ça les a
mis en demeure faut ensuite un auditeur
a sommé les juifs de france
le même jour un auditeur a sommé les
jo-2012 n'est plus se rendre en
palestine occupée sous peine de pénibles
de périr de la même manière que les
colons russe de la discothèque de tel
aviv non la même manière money ont
surmonté la ville autrement dit les
gamines de tel-aviv sont considérés par
la radio ni des années comme des colons
russe beaucoup comme d'écolo il peut
raconter ce que le résultat compte et ce
qu'il veut c'est de dire est faux et
archi faux
et vous connaissez aussi bien la loi
comme moi sur la communication si ces
propos avaient été tenus de la façon que
cet avocat est en train de le dire radio
méditerranée serait aujourd'hui fermée
ont été tenus et les noms fariza taper
sur les doigts ou raconter des histoires
réponse et le csa n'a jamais sur les
doigts et vous vous êtes en train de
mentir et vous mes frères et bien
diffamation mais vous n'allez pas le
court ladjouze et même pas répondu sur
votre livre parce que vous êtes un
spécialiste de la désinformation et de
dénigrement qu'ajouter de plus chez rien
a ajouté monsieur mathlouthi n'a même
pas le courage de ses opinions
le courage assume que je vis seule chose
vous et moi avec l'outil vous êtes il
faut que vous sachiez quelque chose
qu'on a dans la loi de le guen a le
droit de condamner le sionisme
on a le droit de ne pas être en accord
avec le sionisme on a le droit de mettre
en exergue les crimes commis au
quotidien par cette entité sioniste si
ça vous mais on n'a pas le régler et on
a le droit de se demander encore on n'a
pas cessé de louer et l'ifo qui sort une
sautée cet inventaire nous la vareille
mais nous l'avons condamné à main sur
100 m dans le confort de la seine saint
denis est prêt à se tuer jusqu'au
dernier des palestiniens et où jusqu'au
dernier désagréments de vous êtes très
courageux vous êtes de mauvaise foi et
bien si vous êtes tellement vrai courage
et besoin de gardes du corps font
rentrer ici pour vous avez la confiance
et elle montre aussi très bien
renseignés musée rath oui monsieur
tranquille se trouve la fonction c'est
il se nomme qui se trouve effectivement
est agréé il se trouve effectivement
tellement ravie que vous me disiez mais
se trouve qu'effectivement ap qu'après
l'émission mesure va lui ont soumis des
années j'ai reçu des menaces de mort et
j'ai été obligé de porter je rappelle
quand même chose importante c'est
formidable ça c'est la souffrance on
dirait même qu'il va ça je passe à gaza
ça se passe à la phase en france en 2002
radio méditerranéens sont saccagés les
gens sont menacés de mort
relevé des moments j'ai aussi une valve
en lui disant la prochaine n'arrivera
pas à ses amis ne joues et tu ne jouais
pas lui mais jouer mal évident mais je
crois que malheureusement pas d'accord
non ça je souhaite que jamais lui aussi
je souhaite effectivement déjà que
j'étais avec lesquels je suis d'accord
le géant des victimes et se sont
déversés à tous les deux j ai laissé moi
tout seul finir l'émission merci
voilà je me retrouve tout seul aux deux
tiers de l'émission c'est la première
fois que ça m'arrive
j'espère que vous chez vous vous avez
pas me laisser tomber parce que sinon
j'ai vraiment passé la soirée tout seul
voilà bien connu maintenant karim à
recife
il fait poteau et mickey
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors bonsoir à tous les 3 karim 26 ans
dimitri 24 ans et mickaël 23 ans
alors vous rentrez d'une petite semaine
de vacances en irak
ça a dû vous changez d'armentières oui
mais alors on va prendre les choses au
début vous avez pris conscience du drame
des irakiens coincé entre boucher et
saddam hussein en regardant le journal
télévisé
et puis vous avez décidé de partir pas
boucliers humains mais quoi touristes
n'ont même pas à ces touristes
on voulait juste simplement manifester
notre défi envers l'opposition
american way et de l'orne a été
manifesté il ya tout le monde irak voilà
directement en irak voilà c'est bien qu
trocadéro alors c'est karim qui a eu
l'idée un entre guillemets en fait
j'avais les sens j'avais lancé sans
courir à deux jours de la veille avant
de partir j'ai dit et pourquoi pas on
n'aurait pas à bagdad de manifester j'ai
eu la sensation que moi en rigolant
qu'il avait picolé un peu non dadis a
comme ça te dis pourquoi pas en irak
pourquoi pas six mois
j'ai vu à la télé ça se faisait mais que
j'ai dit pourquoi pourquoi pas c'est pas
une blague
vous êtes vraiment aller quoi j'ai
décidé comme ça un jour d'aller en irak
vous êtes allez y c'est pour ça que là
ce soir d'ailleurs faut bien le dire
alors d'abord vous avez pris l'avion
jusqu'à beyrouth au liban ensuite vous
avez pris le bus jusqu'à damas en syrie
et là j'ai pris un taxi assez
extraordinaire l'histoire monter dans un
taxi et vous dites oh mais que bagdad
centre est là qu elle mais qui traverse
le désert bagdad enterrait ya quand même
km entre mm mille kilomètres vous ai
fait 10 km dans la caisse l'a acheté un
pique nique titre en dedans donc c'était
à doullens des cercles maintenant nous
coûter 30 $ chacun 30 dollars chacun
offert 1000 km et 6000 cher moi c'est
tout nous est le mec qui vous a laissé
grandir un peu
alors on nous fait 1000 km qu'est ce
qu'il y avait dans ce désert du sable où
il y avait de temps en temps des gens
des plus tard mais le petit village de
rossi d'arrêter temps en temps oui c'est
un peu ça aussi la frontière pour
pouvoir manger
ouais et les gens comment ils étaient au
début on a eu pas rester normal mais au
début on a peut-être une petite fonction
ben ouais c'était quand même louche
alors vous arrivez à la frontière
irakienne vous dites on est venu pour le
peuple irakien
donc évidemment les mecs vous regardez
vous mettre dans une petite dans une
petite salle d'attenté
ouais et puis après vous avez des visas
gratuits bien gratuit ouais c'est
combien épisode patries charnelles
engine monde et son dollars shanghai non
mais oui et là vous avez rien payer ça
fait des vacances en même temps ouais et
alors ils vous ont réservé le t elle à
bagdad ils ont ordonné au chauffeur de
nous conduire à l'hôtel safir a rien
irak et tout leur poids on s'est
renseignés ils nous ont dit que tous les
frais d'hôtel et et gratuit
la nourriture et on avait une motion de
notre disposition est sympa on se
demande toujours à leurs vacances
finalement et est alors quand le
lendemain vous avez voulu visiter un
petit peu la ville et jardins de
babylone tout ça le taxi était gratuit
aussi intègre atuge juste un petit
pourboire pour voir sur sarre et c'est
normal ouais il est sympa le choix faire
de tout ça pour ça enfin ça je dis
bonjour merci jean louis nous regardent
aujourd'hui tu peux lui parler quoi avec
les anglais français ou anglais
enfin certains irakiens par les français
ouais alors ça s'est passé comment cette
manif avec les vrais pacifiste parce que
vous vous êtes parti comme ça bon là bas
vous avez rencontré des mecs je dirais
dont c'est pratiquement le boulot de
faire des manifestations
donc nous on s'est joint le pire s'est
bien passé
ils ont ils ont pris pour des pacifistes
à sydney s'est bien passé on a manifesté
tous les jours avec eux on a participé
au meeting donc c'était un peu déçu
qu'on sent bien et alors bah ouais donc
dès notre arrivée on arrive à 7 heures à
bagdad dans notre hôtel
donc on a su qu'il y avait une
manifestation à 9 heures donc on a
participé avec eux sans savoir
comment ça allait se dérouler tout donc
bah ça s'est super bien déroulé c'est là
on s'est aperçu qu'en fait tout ce
qu'ils y étaient j'étais venu avec des
associations en fait une manne shield et
tous et qui nous demande et vous êtes
venus comment elle trouve alors là à
expliquer comment on a fait quand il
était en tournée et il ne croyait pas de
trop car ce que nous disons est votre
vision c'est pas possible si nous
n'avions pas se les procurer à la douane
et j'allais chez les navires et toniques
ou tester qui s'est pacifistes et des
français les anglais américains et des
norvégiens et des américains alors le
premier jour il ya une femme qui jette
sur vous en pleurant elle vous dit vous
êtes nos sauveurs quoi c'est à dire que
ils sont accrochés à vous un petit peu
commune comme une dernière chance
c'est un peureux nous voir des gens là
bas tout le monde était content sur les
côtés du monde applaudissait tout le
monde criait et c'était vraiment
chaleureux ils sont comment les irakiens
chaleureux réservé à 15 ans on pourrait
leur reprocher ils sont vraiment gentils
vrai que la population c'est l'une des
faces et wes c'est une des plus
accueillantes que j'ai faites quoi la
population je parle de la population ont
peur ils vivent depuis des années depuis
l'embargo depuis 400 ans ensuite pour la
routine ils creusent des abris
souterrains et même niveau qu'un parent
après gerland on aperçu sur la télé mais
aussi non à noter par ailleurs pas d'en
accrocher n'est rien pour seront
certainement y avait la guerre donc pour
rire alors vers l hôpital et la voyez
des petites filles qui saigne et comme
y'a pas de médicaments à cause de
l'embargo
on pense leur plaît avec du savoir et
pire c'est qu'on peut rien faire ouais
il avait une petite frousse depuis
trousse médicale le premier soin qu'on
voulait leur donner
y a pas voulu apprendre le docteur way
impossible il fait je peux pour l'heure
seul à prendre j'ai pas le droit je lis
que des problèmes il qu'on peut rien
faire vraiment rien faire ça de
médicaments incroyable ce qui se passe à
ses enfants meurent tous les jours
des médicaments en fait c'est pas qu'il
y en a vraiment très peu mais c'est ce
qu'ils sont qui n'ont plus d'argent
qu'ils peuvent les acheter aux [ __ ]
maintenant quand vous voyez au journal
télévisé le soir les images de l'irak ça
vous fait quoi
ça me fait chaud au coeur quand même
ouais comme avoir en écoute et l'irak
d'une oreille même temps d'écouté 2
ouais donc tiré que 13 ans où je me
sentais proche de maintenant franchement
ça nous ferait vraiment chier quoi s'ils
avaient vraiment la guerre l'amour parce
que 10 juin la guerre bat c c'est
écoeurant parce que déjà et souffre mais
quand je vous dis souffre c'est vraiment
ils souffrent et les finir avec des
bombes bon cru alors karim tu as dit
s'il ya des jeunes des cités un peu
influençable qui voient ça je comprends
très bien qu'on ait un qui se fasse
sauter dans une ambassade
c'est vrai qu'au début est bon avant d'y
aller je disais faire des attentats
suicide et tout mais non ça je peux le
comprendre si j'approuve pas mais ouais
quelque part je peux le comprendre parce
que quand je vous dis je suis sorti de
l'hôpital
franchement je me dis punaises c'était
il y avait quand même un peu de haine on
vous dit punaises et des enfants comme
ça ils savent même pas qu'ils savent
rien on fait et ils savent même pas
parler encore et y meurent ils en
meurent tous les jours ça ça meurt c'est
quand déjà vu la guerre quand vous étiez
là bas c'est reparti entre pour les
boucliers humains ok mais pas suffisant
mais non plus que ce serait une légende
en fait on est parti là bas on a
on n'avait prévenu personne quoi nos
familles il savait pas quand ils ont su
qu'on était à bagdad
ben ils vont paniquer c'est clair c'est
normal et donc voilà qu'on voulait pas
non plus
jouer les héros on y est allés s'il y
avait eu la guerre si on avait su tirer
la guerre au lendemain on serait partie
de soirée j'ai fait une fugue ouais si
on peut appeler ça cabral s'est quand
même connu
et
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
telle aventure est maintenant au boulot
dans la lune
on y est
dès hier si jean marc mormeck
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
je suis content que vous soyez là parce
que le 1er mars dernier à las vegas vous
avez battu l'ukrainien gourov et vous
avez conservé jean marc votre titre de
champion du monde lourds-légers wba-wbc
bien alors jean marc vous êtes champion
du monde elle conserver votre titre
il ya quand même deux problèmes le
premier problème c'est l'ambiance dans
la salle le soir du combat
vous avez été traités par les
spectateurs de bâtard de français de
poules mouillées
puisque quand même un peu un comble et
même alors pour les américains
apparemment c'est une insulte terrible
de pacifistes ce qui pour certains est
un compliment est pour eux une insulte
alors vous attendiez à cette attitude du
public américain
un petit peu quand même parce que c'est
vrai que dans les semaines précédentes
qui j'entendais un peu à la radio il
avait comme il avait enlevé le vin
français il commençait à y verser le
champagne rosé
voilà donc je me disais que j'allais
sifflé
mais bon bon ça vous a pas déstabilisés
non du tout assez important quand même
parce que quand on a une salle comme ça
qui est entièrement contre vous ça doit
être difficile d'avoir la gnac pour
frapper non non mais c'est vrai mais je
pense que moi j'étais très concentré
déjà pour mon combat
j'avais acheté vos combats donc en plus
les insultes je les attendais pas trop
parce que je comprends pas que
trouveront pas l'anglais j'ai pas eu
peur mais c'est une chance
alors ça c'est le premier problème mais
deuxième problème c'est que vous avez
quitté les frères acariès qui étaient
vos managers 1 et vous avez choisi de
rejoindre le promoteur américain john
king qui est vraiment une une star du
système où j'étais allé pourquoi avec
john king pour le pognon non non pas
pour le pognon je dire il pouvait
m'offrir les objectifs faire des choses
que les frères acariès pourrait pas
m'offrir
est ce que les frères acariès ont
boycotté la diffusion du match en france
parce qu'on l'a jamais vu ce match si
vous êtes champion du monde mais ça
s'appelle tout le monde en parle mais à
la limite ça pourrait s'appeler personne
en parle parce que un mec est champion
du monde c'est génial depuis cerdon
c'est pas arrivé je crois et les gens ne
parlent pas de vous est ce que c'est les
acariès con qu'on interdit aux chaînes
de télé françaises de filmer votre
combat en tout cas comme vu mon départ
ils avaient annoncé qu'ils allaient
boycotter d'entrée à ça c'est fait j'ai
fait deux championnats du monde ça a été
on a vu à la télé bon le troisième je
suis avec eux un donc je pense que il y
sont pour quelque chose
son participer en tout cas sympa quand
même on se passe un pas nous on a voulu
acheter des images du combat dunkin gala
vous avez un troisième problème c'est
que john king lui quand on l'appelle
pour les voix des images du combat il va
millions de dollars j'espère qu'il vous
en donne un peu de vent mais on verra
jamais ce qu'on va je sais pas bon je
sais pas en tout cas bravo
alors on va parler un petit peu de vous
maintenant vous êtes né à pointe à pitre
à 4 ans vos parents quittent l'île sans
vous pour aller travailler en métropole
votre père dans le milieu hospitalier
votre mère dans dans l'hôtellerie et
vous vous rejoignez vos parents bien
plus tard vous découvrez bobigny les
barres d'immeubles excellent le métro la
neige à l'âge de 6 ans quand vous êtes
arrivé vous pensez que c'est pour des
vacances
vous êtes aperçu que ça va durer
longtemps ouais il faisait froid il
faisait froid et j'ai pas j'ai perdu
tous mes repères
en fin de compte au fil du temps je suis
dit que je restais la jalle à l'école et
je faisais des choses que l'on n'a pas
l'habitude ça a été difficile pour vous
banon et des bus pour s'adapter à eux
mais bon après près ça va après c'est
vraiment ça va très bien mais je n'ai
pas envie de retourner aux antilles non
je suis je pour les vacances oui oui
vous allez partir là ouais départir 15
jours 15 jours profitez-en
alors donc quand vous étiez petits
d'abord vous allez commencer avec le
foot 1 qui après ça a été la boxe et
après vous allez faire l'armée visite en
allemagne pendant 10 mois et fait partie
de la police militaire ces tireurs
d'élite ce qui veut dire faut pas trop
le faire chier non plus et en rentrant
vous allaitez vigiles chez mcdo c'est
une expérience terrible ça d'être
vigilent parce que vous êtes obligés de
taper sur vos copains d'une certaine
façon non non non non non c'était cool
c'était en plus dans le 93 je
connaissais plus ou moins tout le monde
donc il y avait pas trop de problèmes
vraie batterie dell a été alors vous
avez été champion du monde des mi-lourds
en 98 1 et en 2002
m
[Musique]
céline le jean-marc quand ils arrivent
c'est son hymne à 6 357 magnum qui la
composent et ça s'appelle mormeck mbr
tmc mormeck comme son nom
[Musique]
et là vous battez virgil hill ça a été
quand même énorme c'est ce qui vous a
lancé
c'est un combat vous êtes devenu
champion du monde à ce moment là et vous
avez gardé votre titre vous êtes battus
une légende quand même bon pour moi un
verger c'est quelqu'un qui m'a fait
beaucoup rêver quand j'étais plus jeune
et là je voulais absolument le titre
absolument gagner donc ce jour-là à
marseille ça a été fait et les grands
bref pour moi c'est plus grand moment de
poésie jusqu'à maintenant ben le on va
dire virgil hill et dernier combat cobra
egorov way très important pour nous on
pense à quoi quand on défonce à la
gueule d'un mec est ce qu'il faut le
haïr le mec venir
je pense que c'est une grosse envie de
gagner
balleux ailleurs forcément parce
qu'après je dire en s'embrassant serre
la main ça n'était pas financièrement ça
vaut le coup comme ça te finir la gueule
en son bain dans mon cas oui pour
l'instant puisque je gagne banque ça va
poser des questions à lui poser à
mormeck le pays station alors maintenant
on va faire une interview bras de fer
dont je vous posais des questions tant
que je tiendrai le bras de fer
je continuerai mes questions d'accord
donc je répète donc je tiens moi je lui
pose des questions
d'après la nasa
[Applaudissements]
la date est ce qu'il est
et maintenant par ce blind test un blind
test spécial religion ce soir est aux
platines j'appelle manche jean philippe
corti
richard déçoit un peu de paix dans cette
émission
soyez zen
[Musique]
m
il a donné la foi
j'aime
tu es
et voilà un geste heures pour jouer avec
nous max
m
[Musique]
bach bon soir là alors toujours
animateur radio est pour le moins
toujours tout va bien frédéric donc vous
animez sur mcm one to one le premier
lundi de chaque mois à 20h45
c'est la première dif le premier lundi
de chaque mois et après c'est
multidiffusé ou en vf très bien et vous
donc vous est la maman d'un petit bébé
d'un petit bébé qui s'appelle zoltan
abraham zsolt homme abraham
voilà donc il est bien marquée et puis
bah je suis très heureuse d'être maman
pour l'instant ayant des soucis
familiaux dans ma famille et dans celle
d'alexandre je me pensais plutôt à
régler mes problèmes et à faire ma
famille et m'occuper de mon petit bébé
mais c'est vrai que ce que j'écoutais
tout à l'heure ce qui se passe sur le
plateau je trouve ça révoltant qu'on
puisse pas écouté notre peuple je ça ça
me sidère est vraiment nager j'ai du mal
avec ça et j'aimerais bien que monsieur
du koala fut un peu plus de cabanis les
excitants regardez tout seul vous avoir
accès aux douches racisme était dans le
cabanis mois il pourra écouter les
autres
d'accord c'est à dire soit bien on passe
au blind test didier
[Applaudissements]
alors vous connaissez la règle du jeu je
veux l'interprète évidemment je veux
l'interprète et ça peut vous aider
toutes les chansons qu'on va écouter
sont consacrés aux religions ce cas le
lire parce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure ce
que ça donnait le choc des religions
alors vous êtes très attention
philippines
l'interprète le pas avg
mais non
waliboo sarah marshall et 0.20 l'équipe
de frédérique bedos
mais j'espère que vous allez vous
rattraper attention les religions
toujours philippe anne
[Musique]
sort quinze bourg ouais
attention attention oui quoi eu un gros
soufflage non
mais mais comme nous sommes des nous
sommes pour la paix ce soir en est
généreusement et on attention philippa
[Musique]
mais j'appelle l'arc
et
nomack donc ça fait mairie trois points
pour l'équipe de sahraj zéro point pour
l'équipe de football
attention tension philippins avaient
bekhtar mentir là je tiens au nom
l'abonné sourire je suis soufflé
[Musique]
oui
qui a dit bryant mois
[Applaudissements]
attention
c'est vrai
attention ce clip
[Musique]
champion du monde
à la une chanson qu'elle a été obligée
d'arrêter de chanter justement à cause
des menaces qu'elle a subi beaucoup de
gens sales des menaces en ce moment en
tout cas bravo je dirais qu'un truc
mormeck champion du mois attention
[ __ ] annie cordy
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes peut-être aller en irak
mélange de tendre à nous faire mousser
la cgrae l'attention philippe sarre à
dakhla
non
pas au match axelle red attention ça
fait combien méline 7 0
[Applaudissements]
on jouera là vraiment un petit clip sale
à bobigny je crois philippe mais mais
mais mais toi mais toi vaincue et met
toi la donne le panneau amélie ce n'est
pour appeler le ring à mormeck septième
ronde 7-0 donc là philippe mais toi tu
enlèves à la fois fort contrefaits
ouais attention philippe laude
[Applaudissements]
je suis plus corman ça fait 7 1 et c'est
mon petit philippe à moi qui remplace
philippe corti et oui mon garçon faut-il
qu les attentions petit philippe
ça me faisait
oui
intentions
huit ans
attention petit philippe
[Musique]
karim 80
bien sûr qu'il a trouvé celui qui fut
six mois
j'ai eu
le soufflage de corti et quand il a été
appelé en renfort
les agents ont pensé ce n'est plus il me
dit mais je vois qui sait ah ah non mais
ça y est c'est un choix qu'on continue
petit philippe
[Musique]
c'est du lard ayant alors à longchamp
tiens à préciser que philippe corti ne
connaît pas des morceaux qui sont
préparées par béatrice ardisson dont
philippe decaud n'est pas à l'avancé
encore faut-il le préciser alors
attention
nous passons maintenant au bon côté
appelé la manne ans et plus par équipes
c'est chacun pour sa gueule
donc attention maintenant c'est la loi
de la jungle qui commence mais si on est
des pesticides c'est difficile avait là
là c'est fait attention le bon qu'au
petit philippe
[Musique]
jean marc mormeck
les hommes
11 heures
qu'est ce que j'écoutais comme musique
en ce moment j'en ai un peu de tout vous
connaissez l'album de gabès et du bois
ya toujours de la place
il ya toutes sortes de race mais ça
laisse des traces original
demi soeur on continue le super banco
attention petit philippe
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr
les blues
m
la rolls royce al seni
tout s'arrête jamais
le monsieur
beaucoup plus obligés maintenant ces
normes
on passe au mega man copti philippins
[Musique]
ah ouais
je crois que mac sa et les enterre tout
le monde
[Applaudissements]
ouais
maintenant une grande ont qu à et je
dirais que celui ou celle qui va
remporter l'ultra banco sera une sorte
de champion du monde
attention attention ultra bon qu'au
petit philippe
[Musique]
c'est celui qui sait
personnes âgées
oui
le gîte est mort
je
et voilà merci merci à tous c'était tout
le monde en parle
gad elmaleh jechoux le meur à kalou h
avec gad elmaleh à shaba jeune brasseur
roschdy zem et catherine frot ça sort le
19 mars et la débauche choo reddition du
vhs et
normal 18 mars karolina kurkova la
mannequinat métal du monde
pascal seront lentement place de
l'église
chez albin michel et reddition de l'un
garçons de france également chez albin
michel
topick mathlouthi dans son breuvage dont
je n'ai pas le droit de citer le lan
plus une pendant l'émission
merci le sait ça gilles william
goldnadel
le nouveau bréviaire de là
l antisémitisme et antisionisme c'est
chez ramsay mais là messieurs inconnu
l'album s'appelle ville sogood le single
s'appelle le talent qu'ils aillent voilà
jean marc mormeck
bonsoir merci de radio champions
gwp voilà je rappel merci à google earth
one seg
merci à mike garcia sarah bientôt
j'ai remarqué au petit jeu rappel
l'album de gomez et du bois appliquer en
la loi ça sort le 18 mars et le signal
d'un oui c'était ce commissariat
c'est absolument génial reporters sans
frontières l'album s'appelle dignity
avec jean louis murat indochine et
charlélie couture mais la mi temps par
étaient tous tap
attention lundi à 20h50 tribu présentée
par thierry ardisson
[Musique]
je
g
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
m
du tout
[Musique]